good morning
to the criminal justice committee for
hearings today would you please rise and
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
and with that I will open the public
hearing on HP
anyone
give us a second to get our cards in
order
would you like to introduce your bill
good morning thank you Mr chair and
thank you members of the committee
for the record my name is Walter
Stapleton
I am a representative house rep for
Sullivan County district 6 representing
Claremont and Croydon
then I come here today to present HB
38fn
a bill having to do with the bail and
detention
of modifying Provisions in 597.
so that we can attain
some recovery
from the rampant crime that we've seen
in the last couple of years since bail
reform
and make make the law a little tighter
we can't go on the six o'clock news
without
hearing about watching some horrific
crime all over the United States and
including some horrific crimes in the
state of New Hampshire here
and I'm not gonna go and enumerate them
there's more than enough to spread
around
but my the object of my bill is
basically
we want to put some balance back in the
law to enable justices to make
some fair and balanced decisions
by
bringing the weight of evidence from
clear and convincing down to
preponderance of evidence
like a 51 percent versus 75 percent
standard
and why do we need this well
I'm hearing from people who coached me
on preparation of this bill
and other folks that um
the benefit of the doubt
goes too much to the criminal to the
detriment of Public Safety
and judges may be faced with well I got
70 percent but I need 75 so I'm going to
have to defer out to release instead of
detention
so that's a big component of it
um the 2018 bail reform
upset those traditional standards that
we could now have balanced and effective
Justice
the other component is to eliminate
the financial Test Escape patch
if you commit a crime
but you're Indigent financially limited
then you get a special pass
well how do the criminals read this
boy this is this is a real Gumdrop this
is a Christmas present because they're
out and that's the incentive for them
and other people seeing this that oh you
have a special pathway
um
to clear yourself out of trouble
and this is one more thing that is given
to the incentive for crime
and then
um
foreign
provisions of
secured and unsecured bail
we want to take that unsecured
component out of the bail equation
because there's abuse happening there
and I don't have some figures but maybe
some testimony can come forward to see
how much unsecured bail is being
violated
or abused
so we got these three components and
there's others not all of them are in my
bill but these are the three that I
focused on
another one that's not in my bill is um
breach of bail
we don't seem to have a uniform standard
through the state so if crime is
committed and there's um a bail
probation situation in one town and they
come to Claremont and
and commit another one we we can't seem
to use the prior for an aggregation
of um bail and so we're we're suffering
the
the idea of Public Safety is Paramount
in my bill
um
people are are watching the news and
they're watching their neighbors uh
being attacked and people are scared and
they're uncertain of their safety
in their homes in their cars walking on
the street
we need to instill some balance back
into the law
for Public Safety that's got to be
primary
without
um
destroying or or
compromising the constitutionality of
every defendant
but we do need to restore the balance a
2018 bail reform around the country has
been a disaster and if we don't fix it
it's going to worsen
so that basically is the summation of my
presentation here and I would take
questions
thank you um could you speak to
your your thoughts on the uh the cash
bail part of it
um
you you said that you you think that we
should eliminate that
um could you speak to what you think it
should be and also
um how you what do you think about
um the potential for people who are just
so poor that they have no way of getting
out
um if I heard you correctly if the cash
bail yes question yeah
um as to the amount
um
I do not operate within the criminal
justice system and I wish I had some
more experience relative to that
but I really can't say because I don't
know the extent of how cash bail
requirements are are assisted in the
court fair enough in my second part of
the question
um part of the the driving force behind
the change was the argument that
um being poor should not relegate you to
stay in jail what is your response to
that
to the folks that just say look we we
can't I can't afford a hundred dollars
well you know that goes to the root of
the question
um we've given them an escape patch and
that's one of the reasons we see such
Sally an increase in crime all kinds of
crime
if you do the crime you know you've got
you've got an answer for it and you know
if you're found guilty you do the time
and if if you can't come up with the
bail you have maybe family friends or
assistants or bail bondsmen um
you know there are Avenues here that you
have and maybe if you can't make bail
that's going to be a lesson for you
sitting in The Slammer for a while that
um representative Murray
um I was just wondering if you had any
statistics or numbers that could back up
like there being an increase in crime or
is this based on anecdotal evidence
I'm sorry I'm having difficulty hearing
the question my hearing aids are not
working here I'm sorry
um I was wondering if you have
statistics to back up uh your claims
that crime has risen or if it's based on
anecdotal evidence
I I do not have um
statistics
available that that I can readily relate
I'm not being I'm not familiar with this
particular aspect I know there's a
problem I'm citing the problem I bring
them forth to the committee
um perhaps those who are following in
testimony can provide answers to those
questions with a lot more satisfaction
thank you for your testimony this
morning
thank you I am representative Heidi
Hamer Manchester's Ward 10 I am a
lifelong resident of Manchester's west
side
Manchester needs Our Help House Bill 38
FN is a good start to improve the safety
of a public
this is about violent crimes this is
about repeat offenders a person who
violates the terms and conditions of
bail by reoffending numerous times
should be held without bail pending
arraignment
re-offenders need to be held accountable
every time I hear or read about a
serious crime in Manchester it's always
followed by they'll be back out in the
streets to recommit the same crime or
another crime by the afternoon
this must stop
this bill is making sure that a person
who has already committed crimes and who
reoffends over and over again be held
until their cases have been heard
this legislation will make our community
safer
this legislation will help our police
departments this legislation should be
an eye-opener for repeat offenders
please help our police our residents our
business owners by supporting House Bill
representative dry
Dyer dry I get it right it's the first
time
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee for having this hearing I am
Margaret dry representative from
Sullivan County District 7. I live in
Plainfield and the district serves the
towns of Plainfield Cornish Newport
unity and Charlestown I'm a co-sponsor
of this bill and I am in favor of the
bill
last week the Valley news paper up in
our area carried a front page story of
one of the largest seizures of fentanyl
by the Hanover police ever The Saga
started with um Saga started with a
mid-January early morning crash report
from a rental car in the village of
Aetna by the time the police were
statically driving down a Hanover Road
and later
um
uh caught up with in a parking lot in
your downtown Hanover the driver
obviously impaired consented to a
sobriety test and failed and she was
jailed in Haverhill over the holiday
weekend in mid-January meanwhile police
were looking for uh were asking for a
search warrant for her car
but by the time they got it she had been
processed and released
in the car the police found 2200 tablets
of Fentanyl
and worth about twenty five thousand
dollars and 180 grams of meth the drugs
were only discovered after the police
had obtained their warrant but by then
the driver was gone and she is still at
Large
the newspaper story goes on to talk
about how technology in cars especially
rental car we respond to crashes and
other car emergencies
but what's left unanswered is the
question why was this woman released
before her car was searched
perhaps time had elapsed and she was no
longer impaired
however most reasonable people would
think that a previous DUI
being known to police throughout New
England and the fact that a search
Lawrence was in process for your car
would be enough to keep someone in jail
at least until the search warrant is
settled
today you're going to hear from a lot of
people much more qualified than I am on
the technical aspects of this bill but I
wanted to introduce you to a recent real
life example where a change from clear
and convinced convincing evidence to a
preponderance of evidence might have
resulted in someone now known to be
involved in one of Hanover's largest
fentanyl seizures being behind bars
instead of on the loose I urge you to
pass House Bill 38 and I'm willing to
take questions
thank you representative on the case you
just talked about
um she was arrested for DUI a second DUI
second offense DUI did she have any
other charges besides that
as far as I no no are you aware of what
her record was like at all her criminal
record
um I am only what using what's been in
public but I do know people who do okay
all right
um and I'm asking because I'm trying to
put myself in the position of the bail
clerk at the time what they knew or did
not know
um any further questions you know thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you
uh the chair calls David Rothstein
Steen
good morning my name is David Rothstein
I was a public defender for over 30
years including one of the directors of
the program I'm now in private criminal
practice and I'm here on behalf of the
New Hampshire Association of criminal
defense attorneys and speaking in
opposition to changing the bill bill
and full well understanding the the
emotions and the feelings of people who
have proposed this bill full
understanding the the need that we all
have to try to prevent an increase in
crime but not believing that further
um
tinkering with this Veil statute is is
the answer the statute will make it
easier to detain people for a longer
time it'll make it harder for people to
get out on bail and I I don't believe
that that's the direction that we should
be focusing on I think we should be
focusing on a few different things one
is training the people who are involved
in the bail process judges prosecutors
and defense attorneys to come together
to try to make better decisions these
decisions are not necessarily or should
not necessarily be adversarially we
should be trying to look out for what
the best interest is for the community
and for this person and there's a severe
lack of training in this very important
area it just seems to kind of go by the
wayside it's a very short little bit on
the docket these hearings happen they
pass and decisions are made
the second thing that I think resources
should be put into would be information
a lot of times when we're getting these
cases and when I'm called upon to do a
bail hearing for somebody the case is on
at one o'clock I have a short phone
conversation with somebody at the jail I
get some information from them the
prosecutor has their criminal record and
the judges called upon to make a very
difficult decision
in the federal system there's an entire
report that's done by a neutral party
they interview the person they do report
for the judge they make a recommendation
there's a severe lack of information
about the person that I think could
contribute both ways in some of these
cases that may have led to the person
being detained in other cases where
someone is detained that may lead to the
person being released
the third issue is resources a lot of
the people who are being held in jail
are not these outliers the most
dangerous people the people you hear
about in the headlines they're people
who are poor they're people who suffer
from mental illness there are people who
suffer from substance use disorder and
frankly a lot of these people are being
ending up detained in jail because the
judge doesn't want to let them out the
judge doesn't have the community
resources that the judge feels confident
in that if they get out on bail that
there's going to be somebody who's going
to be looking after them getting them
maybe medically assisted treatment
getting them help for their mental
illness there's a significant resource
issue here that could be addressed I
think in in large part we're talking
about humans making decisions about
humans and no matter what you do with
the statute whatever you call the
standard it's still going to be humans
making decisions about humans they're
going to be occasional after the fact
situations where you're going to say
well in that case it seems like a
mistake was made and we can learn from
those situations but I think that
squeezing the the bill on both ends here
where we make it easier to detain people
and harder for people to get out the
most likely consequence is you're going
to have more people sitting in jail who
are mentally ill who are poor who are
suffering from substance use disorder
and sitting in jails that do not have
the capacity to take care of these
people and they're going to be sitting
there for a long period of time far to
their detriment if they were able to get
out of jail and have resources where
they could be productive then in the
long run when their case comes up for
sentencing they're less likely to get a
sentence where they have to go back to
jail so we're not spending money on that
end so I just there's been a lot of of
tinkering with this Bell statute I know
it's well intended I know people are
trying to get it right I I just don't
think there's significant evidence that
that's going to address this problem in
a meaningful way way so I'd be glad to
address any questions anyone has
thank you I have a quick question sure
you said lack of full information and
you compared it to the federal system
what exact information are you talking
about that you feel like is not
available to the judge or bail Clerk or
whoever at the time
right so basic the basic case that comes
up
um you get a call there's a felony's
first arraignment list at one o'clock
you get a call that morning as late as
11 or 12 o'clock there's going to be a
bail hearing at one o'clock so you get
on the phone you talk to somebody who's
at the jail you get some information
from them you don't have the opportunity
to obviously you don't know the person
unless they're a former client of yours
which is unlikely you don't have the
opportunity to to corroborate the
information you do the best you can the
prosecutor is kind of in the same boat
they have a file they look in their file
they say oh this person has no criminal
record this person has a criminal record
this person did not show up for court
therefore I'm going to recommend
detention and the judge has that in
front of the judge and that's that's a
very difficult situation the judge is
not neither side neither the defense nor
the state have a lot of information
therefore they're not able to give the
judge a lot of information and therefore
the judge has to make a call in the
federal system my understanding is that
there is a pre-trial release person who
does sort of a report for the judge I'm
going to testify
um I just have a question from the
perspective of a of a defense attorney
what the what the full impact of the
change in the evidence evidentiary
standards in the bill what how that
would actually play out uh in court in
the legal system right and I think
that's a really good question because
these phrases clear and convincing
evidence preponderance of the evidence
they're they're debated in terms of what
they they mean preponderance of the
evidence typically means more than 50
percent
um so 51 clear and convincing evidence
is below Beyond A Reasonable Doubt but
we don't know exactly where it is I
think that the it's difficult to explain
um
with Precision how it would play out but
I think the message that the legislature
would be sending to to the judges is
that more people should be detained
um that um there should be
um less than clear and convincing
evidence for detention and that if
someone is looking to overcome a
rebuttable presumption on the other side
that they should be released there
should be more there should be clear and
convincing evidence the more than a
preponderance of the evidence so I think
the way it would practically play out is
it would result in more people being
more people being detained it would
result in more contested bail hearings
it would result in in expending more
resources in in terms of the bail
determination just having that battle
over whether the state has met its
standard and I I do think that more
resources should be committed to to bail
to make good decisions I I just don't
necessarily think that changing these
standards or making it
if we're going to make it more likely
that someone should be detained I think
we should be doing it based on that
person's Story the information about
that person I think a lot of times we
fear what we don't understand and if
somebody comes into court and you hear
that they're mentally ill that they're
suffering from substance use disorder
you're like well that person clearly
can't be released maybe they can if you
learn more about them and I don't know
that changing those words or changing
those standards I know the message it
sends but I just don't know that it does
much good for that person
um or for the system as a whole
oh
is is it fair to say that if you change
the words without changing the resources
you haven't accomplished much that
I I think I think that is a good way of
putting what I'm trying to say I think
basically you get the same you know you
get the same problem of this lack of
when I see a lack of training
information and resources you can change
the words but that nothing else is
happening I think there are some
counties like Stratford county has an
active Community Corrections program
it's kind of like a it's kind of like a
pre-trial probation where if they take
you uh if they take your supervision
you're kind of like on probation before
your charge comes up and they know where
you're living and they know
um you know they try to help you get
ideally they try to help you get back on
your feet to try to get a job to try to
take care of your substance use disorder
some people need that they need that
structure and they benefit from that
structure it's very as you hear counties
are very uneven other counties you're
just if you're released you're just
thrown on the streets on a day like this
and that's probably not going to be good
so I do think that resources need to be
addressed
um and resources you know they obviously
cost money but I think if you put more
money into that end I think you're
ultimately saving money on the other
hand because the person is going to do
better and they may not need to go to
representative Newman
I have a question that's kind of a
follow-up to that because it's about a
change of words
so same thing like the question you just
asked what kind of effect would this
have and I'm looking particularly at
section on Roman numeral seven which is
about the second defense and whatever
um that and and it says that the
individuals shall be detained without
shall be detained without bail not may
be detained they change it from May to
shall
you know and I believe that that will uh
could potentially cause people in the
situations that you just described to be
detained in jail for 72 hours
right and I think that well I won't tell
you what I think do you agree could you
just talk about that please Michelle and
may is a much different change I I think
um from uh from the perspective I mean
Xiao mean ciao there's no discretion
that that is given to whether it's a
magistrate which comes up later whether
it's a bail commission whether it's a
judge it has to be that way
um and you know in some cases that that
is probably the right decision
um I think again it depends on the
situation I certainly can see that in
some cases the the right decision if
someone commits another offense while
they're out on bail is going to be that
they shall be held but this if this
wording is any felony any misdemeanor
and that's a pretty broad spectrum of
people I mean there are some pretty
benign misdemeanors and even pretty
benign felonies I'm sorry
uh and my follow-up to that would be
most of your discussion so far has dealt
with people that don't have the
wherewithal don't have what else in the
community of that but will this not have
a uh an effect on anybody who gets
has a second Offense for whatever the
reason and we don't know what it is it
could be a benign reason would it also
have an effect on a large bigger group
of people people who have just committed
one of those crimes and now is caught in
this shall be detained for 72-hour
situation absolutely I think as a as a
practical matter
um the the cases that we see tend to be
people of more limited resources who
have these other issues the mental
illness issues the substance use issues
but you're absolutely correct it would
be it's shall it's anybody so it's it it
covers anyone who commits any other
offense while out on bail as long as
it's a misdemeanor no matter what it is
good morning uh my name is Buzz sure I'm
a professor of law at UNH School of Law
I'm also a elected Police Commissioner
in the town of Portsmouth
opinions and testimony today are my own
they're not those of unh UNH law or the
Portsmouth police commission or
Department
um
before I address the uh investigation
the report that's being passed around a
couple things on what we've already
heard number one since bail reform
passed the crime rate in New Hampshire
is down 18 percent
so uh
that's a from National statistics number
two the change from the language from
clear and convincing evidence to
preponderance to the evidence for a
person to be held without bail
is unconstitutional
under a case named U.S versus Salerno
that requires if you're going to detain
somebody without bail you're entitled to
a due process hearing and the burden of
proof must be by clear and convincing
evidence
uh so uh number three the statute
already addresses repeat offenders there
already exist mechanisms in the statute
to deal with people who commit uh after
they've been released on bail as a
previous uh witness testified it's a
matter of human beings doing their job
um and uh actually raising issues like
that
um let me talk now about
um well I add one more thing uh uh the
sponsor of the bill uh referred to uh
people who are the issues uh surrounding
people who've been charged with a crime
uh and referred to them as criminals
they're not criminals they haven't been
convicted yet
um they uh they remain innocent until
proven guilty and we can't build a bell
system that assumes that they're guilty
that's fundamentally wrong
um the study I I passed around myself uh
and a second year law student Travis
Bennett
um uh
I I did this study
um
I have been as as I talked about last
week
everybody on this committee who's been
here before uh and I'm guessing people
are starting to realize who haven't been
on this committee before that there's
been a lack of data hard data as to
what's really going on in the system
uh and uh that's made it very difficult
for you members of this committee uh for
members of Senate Judiciary Committee to
make evidence-based decisions about what
the bail statute should look like and
how it should uh how it should be
written uh what I've done with uh uh Mr
Bennett is uh we actually have collected
data we contact we we got a a series of
case numbers
from the judicial Council through a 91a
request
those case numbers allowed us to then
call up
the phone number the court system phone
number and request what are called case
summary sheets
which track the history of the case
number what happened with that case the
case may involve one charge three
charges four charges but they're all
relate to one incident and so we looked
at those case summary sheets in an
effort to see to what extent are people
who are out on bail being charged with
additional crimes when they're out on
bail and their bail is uh they're
they're being brought in for a breach of
bail or they're being charged uh uh as
reflected by the case summary sheet with
a uh a breach of bail
um and and that's what we looked at 508
cases we under we understood from the
beginning that much of the focus of this
failed discussion has arisen out of
Manchester uh the concerns expressed by
the Manchester police department and
some Representatives so we focused on
Superior Court in Manchester
Hillsborough County
Superior Court North and we focused on
Manchester District Court
we looked at a total of 508 cases out of
those 508 case sheets case summary
sheets
only four case summary sheets indicated
a breach of bail due to the commission
of a new kind
that could mean two things
very very very few people who are
released either on personal recognizance
fail or some form of cash fail are
actually then committing are being
charged with additional crimes
or it could mean that
if if that's happening
uh prosecutors are not
raising the issue
it with the court that uh originally
released them on pale could be one of
those two things but what we see on the
case summary sheets is
0.79 percent
of the 508 cases involved a
documentation the case summary sheet of
somebody being charged being being found
to be in breach of bail for uh
committing and or being arrested for an
additional offense so that's piece of
information number one
piece of information number two uh which
is the second line on the quick facts
which is the to me the most powerful
piece of information
of the 508 case summary sheets we
reviewed
36.8 percent of them resulted either in
all the charges being dismissed or null
Prost which is the prosecution uh
dropping it rather than the court
dismissing the case
over one-third of all the case summary
sheets we looked at felonies and
misdemeanors
I go back to what the prime sponsor said
that you know we need to hold these
criminals well
that's not actually the case when one
third of the circumstances their charges
are being dismissed that is they remain
innocent
to the extent that we changed the bail
statute
to increase the number of people who are
being held
were we one out of three people being
held uh would be what their cases would
end up being dismissed or dumped by the
prosecutor
so you increase the number of people
being held you're increasing the number
of innocent people being held you're
increasing the number of people whose
cases will later be dismissed that is
they'll be held pending trial for
anywhere from three to six months
perhaps more
charges will be dismissed and they have
interestingly the fourth fact on this
well the third fact here almost all the
cases we looked at involved the
imposition of a jail or prison sense
that was suspended
the huge majority of people in those of
those 508
are not ending up getting a jail
again the population we're looking at is
not people who we need to incarcerate
pre-trial because we know they're going
to get jail sentences later on anyway
and finally
um
speaking of resources of the 334 cases
we looked at that came from Superior
Court Hillsborough County Superior Court
in Manchester
70 almost 72 percent of them
or drug-related offenses
they were not violent offenses
they were not assaults they were not
sexual assaults they were not homicides
they were drug-related offenses
the kind of case that is for lack of a
better way of putting it plaguing our
there's a prosecutors are expending a
tremendous amount of resources
processing those cases the public
defender program
is overwhelmed with drug cases and uh
were and those are as a relative matter
other than the defendants themselves
they are relatively speaking victimless
crimes
so but we need to keep in perspective
the kinds of cases we're actually
talking about
um
thank you um a couple of questions
with regard to the um the charges being
dismissed do you know what percent of
all across the state charges end up
being dismissed uh
no uh for a couple of reasons one the
court system does not have a data
collection system it only has a case
management system so we can't keep track
of that second answer is I'm a law
professor I get to get more than one
answer
second answer is
um
two maybe three years ago I I was at
there was a study committee involving
the office of Cost Containment which is
the agency that collects money from poor
people because they're too poor to
afford a lawyer uh and there was
testimony by uh an individual from the
court system and the individual the
executive director of the public
defender program at that time that
somewhere between 25 and 33 percent of
all court appointed cases that the
public defender got were dismissed or no
press so this data in this sample of of
case summary sheets is consistent with
uh what I heard two three years ago at
that study that that's a part of that
study committee and my last question is
in the subset that you looked at
what if you know or were able to glean
from it what were the the reasons that
they ended up being dismissed or null
Pros well that is not revealed in it's
you know in the case summary sheet it
just says dismissed or no process okay
thank you representative Newman
thank you thank you for taking my
question and it's it I'm going back to
the question that I asked earlier in in
your research that you had
when you get a situation like a regular
citizen who has the first offense and it
may be a misdemeanor that doesn't have
any uh jail time with it and then maybe
they get a minor drug
thing that that would be their second
offense under this bill how How would
how would that affect the the that
situation which encompasses a lot of
people do you have any any thoughts on
that that you could help me with yes a
couple thoughts number one
we didn't see prosecutors offices either
in District Manchester District Court or
Superior Court
bringing breach of Baal arguments in
front of the court who released that
individual on the first offense
by virtue of the second offense being
being charged that is they weren't
calling they weren't they had the
mechanism under the current bail statute
to file a motion in court saying this
person violated the conditions of his
bail on that original misdemeanor and
therefore we think they should be held
or their bail should be they should be
have to put up cash bail we saw
virtually none of that uh happening
so I understand about when you go
strictly by your study of breach of Baal
um in situations where it's not a breach
of Baal do you think that the change
from uh from shall where the discretion
is taken away from the person
determining the bail
will have an effect because of the
change to shall yes it will have an
effect and and that provision too is
unconstitutional you you have to have a
hearing
uh to determine whether the person uh is
worthy of being detained preventively
preventatively be it at the front end
when the bail is first set or towards
later when there's an additional issue
raised uh there still needs to be a
hearing with a clear and convincing uh
standard of proof for it to be
constitutional
could I ask just one quick thing that he
said about the the condition of bail
just to get my
so you said that they have to have a
hearing to have due process yes it is
not that hearing in front of the bail
commissioner or whoever the judge is is
that not a hearing and wouldn't that
fulfill
the uh the due process requirement
well if if the judge has no choice
if the word is shell there's not going
representative saley
thank you Mr chair and as the daughter
of a law professor I understand the
verbosities my apologies to you um and
um so we we heard some testimony
um in the introduction of this bill that
talked about one potentially I guess one
might consider it an egregious case of
someone being released who maybe
shouldn't have prior to something
um I'm curious if there have been cases
in New Hampshire that you're aware of
that would be egregious in the other
direction such as the case of the young
man who was held on Rikers Island in New
York for having stolen a backpack that
was valued at 25 and was held for three
years while he awaited trial because he
couldn't make the hundred dollars bail
um
certainly there's such cases exist
because uh inevitably if you know 37
of cases uh uh where bail is set 37
percent of them are being dismissed some
of them will involve people who are
preventively detained
um I don't have
in mind a specific case
um
I'm old now so the memory fails me but
thank you if if you or your um student
assistant have the opportunity to just
take a look to share any evidence of
anything later um that would be
wonderful thank you I'll make every
effort to get that kind of information
provided to the committee thank you
um one more question it occurs to me the
the case summary sheets that you on your
um your assistant studied is it possible
that um a new arrest would be on a
separate case sheet
in other words that goes yeah it's
possible
um but if it were uh it's very possible
um but
if they wanted to have a hearing
to hold this person because of the
subsequent arrest after being out on
bail they would and they would need to
bring it up in that case
um so it's possible that
um the uh prosecutors uh
I think it's very possible that
prosecutors understandably in many ways
they're not that closely monitoring
every single case they have they are
like the public defender system they are
understaffed and they're overwhelmed
with cases uh and in the example that
representative Newman talked about if
it's if they're out on PR bail on a
misdemeanor and they could and they're
arrested for another relatively minor
misdemeanor
prosecutors very likely not going to
notice that because he's now waking up
every morning coming into work and
looking
at every single case he has to see what
activity there would be
um so you know that's a
um
they it's a matter of triage for lack of
a better way of putting it thank you
thank you for taking my question
um I know with
504 instances of people being actually
released on bail and not committing a
second offense
um that that's a pretty staggering
number that's over 99 percent
um but what I'm curious is the reason
we're all here today is because of that
other uh 0.79 of cases the four cases
where people did commit a second offense
while they were out on bail
I mean taking a look at those summary
sheets
um what sort of lessons can you glean uh
for police for prosecutors uh for was
there some sort of failure in the system
itself that we can address
yeah I would say the failure
I hate to use the word Phil it's a
systemic failure in that there's not
enough prosecutors to follow up on each
case in which a person is released on
bail you know I think it is
um uh that's the fundamental
problem
if in fact a lot of people if a big if
if in fact there's a lot more than the
0.79 actually being arrested for
subsequent offenses after being released
on bail you know it's it it's hard to
say as much as I would like to say
you know only point you know over 99
Point what
99.2 percent of people released on bail
are not committing us are not being
arrested for additional offenses yeah we
can't say that with certainty because of
the
the the the kind of data that is not
available
um but we you know it suggests to me
that prosecutors at the least
are not seeing a lot of people released
on bail committing serious enough
offenses to want to file a uh a motion
to revoke Baal we're just not seeing
that that is certainly the case why
they're not you know that's their
judgment again go back to what a prior
witness said humans administering a
system
involving humans and and uh
I guess the ultimate lesson I would take
from this is
um
we don't need to change the bail statute
the bail reform statute that was passed
four or five years ago we there is
plenty of flexibility to deal with all
the circumstances that have been raised
in testimony before this committee over
the last four or five years in efforts
to pull back on ballot reform the
statute doesn't exist now is completely
capable of dealing with all these
circumstances if the system is working
well
we can't fix a poorly working system by
changing the statute it'll just make it
worse
the chair recognizes Frank Knack from
Mr chair members of the committee thank
you so much for the opportunity to
testify today my name is Frank kinack
I'm the policy director with the ACLU of
New Hampshire
um most of the um uh what I was planning
on discussing has already been touched
on by Professor sure and Mr Osteen so
I'll refer you to my my fact sheet for
additional background on on the those
issues
um I want to touch on a couple of issues
that were raised by the prime sponsor
um I think one was this notion that we
are providing a special pass to poor
people by eliminating going back to the
cash bail system that we had before by
eliminating the protection against
um pre-trial incarceration for those who
can't afford it and I think it's just
really important to look at it this is
we are not creating special any type of
special paths to poor people we are
ensuring that people with wealth and
people with without wealth have the same
opportunity for release that we are
making decisions based off of whether
someone should be detained based off of
dangerousness or Flight Risk and not how
much money they have in their bank
accounts which is what we would do if we
if we passed this law we would have
situations where person a with wealth
you know committed the same offense this
person be without wealth personally with
with wealth would just be released
because they could pay for their bail
person B without wealth would just sit
in jail and that's fundamentally unfair
and un-American
um
I also want to touch on
um a few aspects that I think haven't
been hit on today so one is the section
of the bill
that would basically allow for uh
mandating
pre-trial holds for people who are
rearrested for any offense again this is
any offense so includes Class B's that
are not jailable even if you're
convicted and given the maximum
punishment as you heard from Professor
sure not only is it you know the fact
that you wouldn't if you got convicted
and got the max punishment you wouldn't
be eligible for jail but a lot of these
folks will have their case dismissed and
so
um there there are not going to jail
anyway because they didn't do what was
alleged but under this bill you know
these folks can be held for up to six
days and so I think as you all heard
from the clinical Professor last week
and testimony on SV or HP 318 you know
six day even one day of hold is a huge
burden on people you can pull them away
from their families and their their
family obligations if they have kids or
elderly parents who they're watching
they can lose their job you know they're
taken away from education they're taking
away from Access to Health Care all
their responsibility all these and
that's one day this bill would allow for
up to six days and that's unconscionable
from our perspective I think it's really
also important to talk about the fact
that this bill is framed as a public
safety bill when in fact it's actually
the opposite there's substantial
research that shows that pre-trial
incarceration is one of the worst things
we can do if we actually care about
public safety and because in fact of
what what you heard from the professor
last week that you're moving people from
their systems that you are making that
setting them up for failure and
additional hurdles when they are
released
I point to a few studies in my fact
sheet but one where they looked at over
a 10-year period 1.5 million cases in
Kentucky and they found that holding
people for as little as 24 hours has a
net Public Safety harm because you're
removing people from their from their
from their Sports systems you're taken
away from their jobs from their from
their families and so while we're not
saying that no one should be held we're
saying it should be based on individual
determinations on dangerousness by in
with the facts and case and not having
one size fits all approaches which this
bill would do
and just also reiterate the fact and
you'll see in in the handout I gave you
the Myriad ways under current law that
people can be held have their bail
revoked if they commit a new offense and
also which we have never heard um from
from proponents a response to is there's
also a section in current code that
allows prosecutors to challenge any
release order they disagree with and
I've never seen anyone bring that up a
case where that's come up and finally I
think we heard about this and I think
representative you had asked about
public safety and and crime stats and so
we thought it was important to actually
look at what the data shows and so since
Bill reform was passed in 2018 between
2018 and 2021 which is the most current
year of data available on the New
Hampshire Department of safety's website
crime in New Hampshire is down 18 for
group a crime so that is almost all
crimes all of the violent crimes in New
Hampshire down 18 percent in Manchester
what you've heard about is having
alleged problems is time is down 13
percent since bail reform so the notion
that somehow Borough form has made our
communities less safe is not backed up
by any data and so I'm not sitting here
saying that bail reform is the reason
that crime is down because then that
would also be disingenuous but the fact
that the other side is trying to spin it
um is just is troubling and happy to
um we during these hearings and there
are going to be several like them to
cover uh cover numerous bills um
oh
one of the things that we
um one of the things that we hear
um I'm sorry I lost my train of thought
I'll catch you afterwards
I'm sure it was going to be a very good
question
um it was going to be awesome I believe
it was
they're bringing all the questions thank
you for your testimony thank you so much
and the chair recognizes attorney head
foreign
good morning members of the committee my
name is Richard head I'm the government
Affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch I wanted to focus on one part of
the this bill
um
and only comment on on that part some
beginning on page three
starting at line
which makes a modification to existing
law and and there was some discussion
about it earlier that changes a May to a
shall
um in in that section
in in my comments are not with regard to
the policy behind it you've heard other
people speak to that but it's as to the
impact on the on the judicial branch and
what that means first I also just wanted
to
um sort of make clear what this section
relates to which is not just those who
are released on bail this is this
section when you read it talks about a
person charged with an offense who is at
the time the offense was committed
and this is the list on release pending
trial for a felony or a misdemeanor
under federal or state law
release
pending imposition or execution of the
sentence an appeal of the sentence or
conviction or completion of the sentence
so from the from the time a person is
arrested on bail
through trial through or or settlement
through completion of sentence of that
crime if they are rearrested this
provision would kick in and the shall
now applies to that large group of
people because it's all felonies and all
misdemeanors so it could be a
misdemeanor trespass
where they were they had some sort of a
sentence that lasted six months it may
have taken them close to eight nine
months to actually have trials so the
total period of time might be you know
close to a year and a half where this
so what does that mean in terms of the
courts and and what are we currently
dealing with we have 40 and I'm going to
focus on Circuit Court
um uh not so much Superior Spears
felonies
um last session you passed the repeal of
felonies first so all felonies beginning
January 1 are going to start in the
circuit court so those bail decisions
are all going to be circuit court issues
If This Were to pass
but I'm going to talk about current
they're currently in in circuit court is
not just district with criminal Circuit
Court means District Division Family
Division probate Division and all of the
judges hear all of the cases
there are 42 full-time judges so up
until the vice chair returned back there
are 14 of you math was a little easier
you gave me a little extra person
if if we have 15 people here we have 42
judges it's a little less than three
times the group that's here hearing me
speak today so 42 full-time judges we
also have six part-time judges they
receive on average 127
000 cases a year it's a lot of cases
that come through there we've also
recently completed what's called a
weighted caseload study in uh in about a
minute the chief justice is going to
begin explaining that to division one
he's got two hours I'm hoping to take
about two more minutes of your time if
you do want to learn a lot about our
weighted caseload study he is I assume
that's being recorded and would be
available in talking in division one
if you take the the total number of
judges and you convert those into judge
days so the number of J days a judge is
sitting and can sit and if you have 42
plus the six part-time and you assume
they don't take vacations they don't
take holidays off there are 249 session
days per judge so a judge sort of caps
out at 249 session days per judge
if we take those hundred and twenty
seven thousand cases
we need six a little over 16
000 judge days so we have a little over
ten thousand we need current case load a
little over we have to be able to fill
16 000. that's why judges are rushing
some people
um so some of these hearings get sort of
pushed along they may have you know
needed a an hour they may have to they
may only have a half hour you know some
of those are just getting pushed through
if we take another little subset in
everything that has a
statutory deadline I'm not even counting
constitutional deadlines but if there's
a case that has a statutory deadline has
to be heard within five days 10 days 14
days something like that that in and of
itself is 5 000 uh judge days so it's
about half of the total available judge
days are just on those things that have
a statutory deadline so that's why you
might hear complaints about in my
divorce case took too long my small
claims case took too long
the things that have mandatory deadlines
have to get filled first constitutional
deadlines have to get filled in we have
a little over ten thousand session days
available we need about sixteen thousand
that's why you're going to hear the the
Chief Justice asking for more judges in
the course of of uh of his budget
presentation when he gives it
and really what we're talking about
though is so all of those bail hearings
have to go in front of a judge
um and those are Judges that are full
with what they already have a little bit
overflowing with what they already have
then you add in what is the impact on
staff because every one of these
cases that are coming in for a bail
requires a staff person to do all the
paperwork get that thing everything that
needs to be done to get that in front of
a judge
we like everybody else who runs a
business we have a short shortage and we
may actually may be doing a little
better than some maybe not um
the weighted caseload says that we need
338 Court staff throughout the system we
have 323 uh positions and we have about
40 35 vacancies so we're short even at
full capacity we're short the number of
Clerks we actually need and we're short
anyway because we can't actually fill
all the positions
so then
what are we talking about when we're
talking about bail reform we're talking
about moving a case that doesn't need a
bail Hearing in some and we're already
factoring in those cases that have bail
hearings so these are things that are
not requiring a bail hearing they're
currently being decided by a bail
commissioner or they're being issued as
summonses not as as an arrest warrant so
they don't come through the bail process
so a lot of misdemeanors would have that
we are talking about a very under just
that section I I pointed out to on page
three
a significant increase in load coming
into this system and that system doesn't
have capacity for additional load
if you add on to that and it's not
factored into these numbers the repeal
of felonies first
everything that is currently starting in
Superior Court is going to shift into
circuit course so that 127 000 cases I
talked about on average you have to add
another 10 000 cases because that's
they're about ten thousand felony cases
in superior court filed and those are
getting shifted over already to this
appear in into the circuit court system
might ask for this particular bill is
that that section be taken out and I've
spoken with a sponsor and I've indicated
that was going to be our ask on this
bill and that be incorporated if the if
as a policy matter you want to bring
that forward that would be put into the
other sort of bail reform that's talking
about
things that require more bail decisions
representative Barry's bill has
something similar to this but not
exactly this
but my only ask is is that this be
discussed in terms of the overall
capacity of the system to absorb the
additional workload that that these
types of additional bail hearings will
cause within the system
um
the weighted caseload study is just
completed last year it does have an
impact in terms of what we're what the
chief justice is asking for in terms of
the court system budget request
and and it asks for more judges more
staff even if we get those there's going
to be a a sort of build up we have to
absorb the current system with that and
then add into anything adding anything
into it
is is the next step so we're just asking
that it'd be that with regard to this
particular bill that portion which would
be page three beginning line 27 through
Page four line three
be pulled out of this one and add it
into the other bills the only other and
my last comment would be is by
converting it from a May to a shell it
also assumes
everybody has knowledge at the time of
rest and at the time of rest what this
bill would require is that the officer
have an understanding of what the status
is of that individual relative to any
prior crimes from bail through
completion of sentencing and and my
understanding is that information is
simply not there at the time of arrest
so it it raises at least concerns as to
what are the implications of that if if
the arresting officer unless they're
familiar with the individual they've
been in the in their community and
they're they're well aware of them uh or
[Music]
um
I don't have a I I think that just
requires a further development of an
understanding as to exactly what does a
police officer know and can they have
this knowledge and if not what is what
is going to be needed from a systems
wide basis to get that knowledge to
interesting officers so at that time
they can make an under a a an informed
decision as to whether or not any of
these criteria apply to the individual
in front of them so that they would go
through the right channels and with that
I would conclude my comments but I'd be
thank you one of the things you did was
you're very clearly outlined how the
system would be overloaded
um one of the things I'd like to know a
little bit more about is what happens if
we pass a bill like this and we overload
the system uh in the way that you talked
about what what are the practical
consequences on the ground for people
trying to get Justice in New Hampshire
um so thank you for the question the the
implication is that we triage so
everything in circuit court is done on a
on a triage basis so you know on any
particular day you have
um bail is is going to be a day so
Monday morning is is bail Monday
afternoon is Criminal throughout that
process you have domestic violence
petitions being filed you have
um uh dcyf filing emergency petitions
those have to get addressed so those are
done on an emergency basis then you deal
with anything that has a a deadline that
the legislature has imposed into the
system so if it's uh a landlord tenant
case those have to get heard within I
think it's 14 days
you have the things that that require
sort of that are driven by a deadline
that's set by a statute or or outside of
that that you have the Constitutional
deadlines of speedy trial and whatever
it may be so then you have
things that don't have those associated
with them
um those simply don't get heard as
quickly so those get pulled in where
there's an opportunity the small claims
cases the probate cases or at least the
orders
and uh
uh marital cases whatever it may be that
doesn't have a strict deadline simply
get triaged later into the system
um and that's that's just a practical
reality they all get heard they'll in
and these judges do and and more
importantly Court staff are just doing a
remarkable amount of work and do it
remarkably well uh and and do it in a
way that the system works but it is at
capacity and it's overflowing um so you
do hear complaints about some stuff
thank you for your testimony thank you
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who has not submitted oh
has anyone else wishing to testify
they're being none here by closed public
hearing on HP 38 and open the public
who's introducing the bill
oh
I recognize representative Harry
thank you Mr chair I'm representative
Linda Harrier gathright out of Nashua
Hills 10.
I am here to introduce
um the magistrate bill
that we've heard quite a bit about over
the last couple weeks
um
there are changes to the bill
unfortunately we don't have an amendment
but at some point it's going to be
introduced
um by attorney head
um
but I want to read um
490k which is
um
definitely a definite change from the
bill you might have received from
um earlier I think I did pass out some
another bill to you guys as well but I
um for 90k one appointments and
qualification the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court in consultation with the
Chief Justice of the superior court and
the administrative judge of the Circuit
Court shall appoint magistrates in such
numbers as are necessary for the
effective administration of justice
substitute subject to Appropriations by
the legislature such magistrates would
serve as such locations as the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court in
consultation with the Chief Justice of
the superior court and the
administrative judge of the Circuit
Court May determine under this chapter
magistrates shall be judicial branch
employees
um I believe that's significant because
what happens there is um the plan is to
develop a training and those magistrates
that would be hired would actually
report to a um
I think it's a director of magistrates
or someone that would be someone over
those magistrates
another important piece of this bill is
there was much complaint about holding
folks for 72 hours some for misdemeanors
something that they wouldn't even be
held for prior to that
um
this would be a 24 7.
offer
you know because they would be 24 7. I
think when we did the circle of course
we realized that with the cert hiring
Circuit Court judges for example still
meant that they were not there on the
weekend or holidays this is different
and that's one of the main reasons why I
think this is a good build that was
presented by the judicial Department
and I support it wholeheartedly and I
surely hope that everyone here would
support it as well and one of the other
things that came up um in terms of um
the um
bail being a being a Baler that you
could still
um you can become a magistrate that's
not off limit to you and you do not have
to have a law degree so just want to
clear that up a little bit and I did
speak with um someone the last week
about that as well so you're gonna hear
a lot more testimony we've heard a lot
but you still more to be heard so I'm
gonna
say thank you for allowing me to
introduce and be a part of this bill
I just if I could just ask you one
question this this would also allow for
a videotape failings would it not yes
uh good morning again just uh very
quickly for the record David Rothstein
um here on behalf of uh nhacdl the New
Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers the association uh in
principle supports this bill
um it dovetails well with a lot of the
things that were were just discussed and
as I understand that the committee has
been discussing about bail
um in that we just heard uh from
attorney head that the system is highly
stressed in terms of resources that what
we're going to be facing at the
beginning of 2024 in the circuit courts
they're going to go back to hearing a
lot more bail cases I I practiced uh
obviously before felonies first and the
circuit courts had to hear a felony bail
cases in the first instance rather than
the superior court so to the extent that
the bill can provide
um an an intelligent and focused
commitment of resources to allow the
courts to more uh to to more
economically efficiently and more
expertly address issues such as bail and
related issues such as issuing uh arrest
warrants and search warrants uh it
sounds like a good commitment of
resources I obviously in terms of
exactly how this works in terms of the
finances and the the policy behind it I
really can't speak to that but if you
were to create a system where you have a
magistrate who is well trained who is
well versed in the issues of bail who is
well-versed in the resources that are
available in the community
um and and who knows the players and and
who can invest the time necessary to
make intelligent bail decisions it
sounds like it's promising as the court
knows in the federal system there's a
magistrate that largely deals with bail
why largely deals with search warrants
and pre-trial issues and probable cause
issues and that magistrate develops an
expertise over time and that magistrate
the work that the magistrate does frees
up the judges to to be able to do other
work that's pressing on the system so
for those reasons at least in principle
it sounds like a good bill just the
caveat being that you know you still
need to be properly trained and
resourced to make bail decisions just if
you're a lawyer it doesn't necessarily
mean you're going to make a better bail
decision than a bail commissioner the
person still needs to be trained but it
sounds like from the prior testimony
there's going to be a premium put on
training and supervision of the
magistrates to try to to get to the
right individualized decisions in each
case so the the organization nhacdl
thank you are there any questions no if
there are no questions thank you well
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for having me uh for the record I am
representative Margaret dry from
Plainfield representing Sullivan County
district 7 Plainfield and Cornish
Newport unity in Charlestown I I'm
opposed to this bill
um two of my immediate constituents
nearby contacted me about this bill
because they are bail Commissioners and
so I've had extensive conversations with
them
I know from personal experience the time
that it takes bail Commissioners to do
their duties in the state of New
Hampshire
in fact while I was talking to one bail
commissioner about this he was
interrupted with a call for his Services
up in Lebanon I also serve with him on
the volunteer rescue squad and I can't
tell you how many times he has either
been called out while we were you know
in service or it was coming back to or
about to go to a a bail
commissioner duty of his uh it
emergencies medical emergencies don't go
by nine by five calendar uh weekday
schedule and neither do the
opportunities for bail Commissioners to
be put into service and I just believe
that a small amount of magistrates at
the cost of about a million and a half
dollars can never meet the
round-the-clock need that over a hundred
essentially free bail Commissioners
already provide to the state
I think a better use of our money might
be to take them the money designed for
training in this bill and apply it to
the bail Commissioners that we already
have so I ask you to please vote this
itl
thank you for your Testament are there
any questions for the representative
we hear a lot of
um information about bail Commissioners
and the great job that they do and the
low cost that they do it with and and
all of the things that they have to put
up with doing that job
um
so I'm just curious since you have
knowledge about that
um do you foresee that there could be a
a better
um
solution for the problem that we
currently have with the bail
commissioners
and that would be more effective than it
is in cost less than this what exactly
would you say about that two problems
came up thank you for your question two
problems came up when I discussed it
this is all new information to me as
well one of the problems is uh that the
fee that they get is minimal it's forty
dollars but they have to collect that
themselves and a lot of time that is not
forthcoming so they're putting out the
service they're doing the job that we're
expecting them to do and at all hours of
the day and night and they're not
getting paid for it they really don't
have a recourse for that so A solution
for that might be just that the court
collects the
um the fee for them and pays them the
other is what I said before
um
training there's not training available
it's it could be a lot better system of
training for these people and and then I
think those two would go a long way to
do you think that uh that would be able
to track enough people to to follow that
and do you think they would still I mean
I don't know what the fee is going to be
but I assume that the high cost for the
magistrate is that the salary for that
is more is a lot more than you would
collect off of any individual fees
so do you think we'd be able to attract
enough people to do that what is the
only solution if you want to use
magistrates to have
many as many as are needed to be able to
do it 24 7 because the proper resources
have been permitted
thank you for your question what I
believe will happen is that you will
retain the people that you already have
and that's over a hundred people and and
I think if you solve the problems that
they're bringing up about being paid and
about being trained then you might be
able to keep the force that we have
that's already in place and already
experienced
thank you
I I just have a question if the
if the fee that the bill if the person
is not paying the fees to the bill
commissioner and that money is put into
the court system to be collected as fees
and the person does not pay their fines
where would that money come from
well I just personally I thank you for
your question I think that the the
judicial system has a little more
influence on on getting the forty
dollars which is pretty minimal price
um to to
repay the Commissioners for their work
uh that they have more influence than
the Commissioners do as by evidence the
fact that they don't get paid and don't
have a recourse to get it I think we can
work a way that we could transfer those
funds to them that that would be covered
they would be covered first and the
judicial system would would just tack
that on to whatever expenses else they
have to be done I hope that if they
trained people and if you put a little
pressure on then maybe we could solve
this problem without resorting to a real
are there any further questions
thank you madam chair
um I'm going to be shockingly brief
um
over the last five years one of the most
common complaints we've heard uh from
the police and prosecutors is the
irregularity of the bail commissioner
system there are really good bail
Commissioners and there are bail
Commissioners who
um
are at least from the police perspective
not performing in a way that the police
think they should be
what this bill does uh is
regularized the system standardize the
system in a way that will have more
predictable
decisions
from the first person setting bail
and I think that's a good thing and I I
would emphasize that my understanding uh
from representative Harry gathright is
that you know uh people who are bail
Commissioners now can apply to would we
be able to apply to be magistrates so
it's not in it's not a lit we're getting
rid of the people who are now bail
Commissioners it it's creating a better
system and once again we're back with
the uh we uh with
um you know we need to put these this is
a a very good allocation of resources to
improve the system
um I and I uh I know there is some
discussion of this when representative
Lynn presented his bill to add three
Circuit Court judges uh last week
if if this committee is not inclined to
vote
ought to pass on this bill uh which I
would urge them to do I think it would
make a lot of sense to have a study
committee
focused on this Staffing issue
magistrate bills
magistrate judges uh bail commissioners
have a study committee where the
committee looks at or a commission looks
at the Lin Bill and Harriet gathwright's
bill I think that might make a lot of
sense
representative jandron
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question
uh I'm going back in history a little
bit here uh I remember in my town we had
a municipal court Municipal Court had as
a magistrate a Justice of the Peace
and when the Municipal Court went away
which heard
bail hearings before they went to the
district court which is now part of the
circuit court system
they actually heard those please and set
bail at the municipal court level now
the Municipal Court
Justice was a Justice of the Peace
our bail Commissioners now are
justices of the Peace So
the the person that testified just prior
to you uh said the money that is
proposed in this bill
uh is better spent
on training for our justices of the
peace slash bail Commissioners would you
agree or disagree with that uh I
disagree I I you know I uh one not all
justices of the peace are bail
commissioners
I think this makes the magistrate judges
full-time employees of the court system
and there's a lot more that will in to
get a lot more supervision
what's the right word they'll be uh more
uniform hiring practices
and I think you will be certain that
you'll always get have a Magistrate
Judge there to manage the incoming cases
I know depending on where you are in the
state it sometimes can be very difficult
to get magistrate judges so I I'm I'm an
advocate of more formally folding
uh
the tasks that bail Commissioners do
into the court system on a full-time
basis you know at a at a certain point
representative general you know it
becomes uh what do you call it
um you know do you do you keep bail
Commissioners and just
put the word bail commissioner in this
instead of Magistrate Judge but still do
everything else this bill bill does you
know it's unclear when that's really
what we're doing or not doing out of
curiosity what Municipal Court were you
talking about
my hometown of Seabrook
I appeared in that Municipal Court
see no further questions thank you thank
you
good morning chairman Rose and good
morning
committee
all right I am Thomas Anderson I am a
bail commissioner I live in francestown
and I work primarily in the Goffstown
and Hillsborough district courts and the
Hillsborough County North Superior Court
uh
I think you I'm not going to bore you
with what we do because you all know
what we do
I think it's important to know how we do
it
and while
remote Bales are in some cases necessary
I'm not a proponent of that
my view is
it's important to the police it's
important to the defendant if we have a
face-to-face meeting in order to
establish whether or not you're going to
be released
and so my view is my personal view is if
I get a call at two o'clock in the
morning as I usually do I will drive to
whoever calls me
because I think it's important
in some cases remote Bales may be
appropriate if you're talking about a
warrant for say a traffic violation or
actually a traffic violation
but getting back to my point about
making personal appearances anything
that involves domestic violence or
driving under the influence
my personal view is I will appear in
person to make a determination as to
whether or not the defendant is under
the statute
dangerous
and I use essentially four criteria in
domestic violence cases
one
was the victim significantly injured two
was a weapon involved
three
was the defendant resisting arrest
violently and four is their intoxication
involved
it all factors into my view face to face
with a defendant as to whether or not
that person is is dangerous
and I think in making that determination
remember the victim has rights as well
as the defendant
and I can issue a criminal bail
protective order
which tells the defendant you can't have
contact with the victim you can't go
back to where the offense took place
but keep in mind that's a piece of paper
and if I think that the defendant is
going to reoffend that night and go back
and
revisit the victim then I'm going to
place that person in custody
I think it's
a simple choice
when I look at this bill pardon me while
if I can get a clarification from the
chair
is Roman numeral two in 490 K1
conducting arraignment hearings and
issued decisions on arraignments is that
no longer applicable
because the bill has been amended
what you're seeing here is is how is how
it would read from here anything that is
if you look on the next page on line 13
do you see where that's crossed off
that would be what is taken out am I
foreign
okay so I sorry I believe I answered
that question correctly so what you're
what you're reading under you know 490k
this is this is how the law would read
and then as an example if you look over
at the next page on line 13 it says if a
person is ordered release and then where
it's crossed off by a bill commissioner
and then it says on bail that is how the
new how the new
amended RSA would read
so if I understand the purpose of the
bill you want to or the bill wants to
replace a hundred bail Commissioners or
so who work at no cost to the government
with 15 magistrates who are going to
essentially support 11
Superior Courts
tangs circuits with 34 district courts
and 200 or so police departments
I don't think it's going to work and I
don't think so because again looking at
the bill
the magistrate would fix the amount of
bail on all days of the week and at all
times of the day and I'm going back to
my point of
are we going to be doing remote Bales is
the mattress we're going to be doing
remote Bales and if so
how does that Advance the ball
if you're dealing with somebody who was
arrested for DUI or domestic violence
and you're doing
the bail assessment remotely I don't
think that advances the ball at all I
think that's dangerous
and so basically on that point you know
we're all volunteers
basically we get a fee if it's paid
we're volunteers but then you know that
because you're all volunteers
essentially
and this whole state runs on volunteers
I've been a member of a number of boards
and committees in my hometown
and I understand you can't run enough
you you can't operate without volunteers
and
in this environment
because things are so expensive and
costs are going up it's important to
keep your volunteers
with that
does anyone have any questions
representative breed
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question
so they spoke to
Commissioners bail Commissioners being
able to become
magistrates and
employees of the state do you think that
how do you think the bail Commissioners
feel about that and do you think more
training and the fees being paid with
the court fines do those three things do
you how do you think the bail
Commissioners feel about that would feel
about that thank you for your question
for your testimony well I'd be reluctant
to comment on what other bail
Commissioners feel about I can tell you
how I feel about it and I don't think
that again it doesn't Advance the ball
if you look at the at the bill the first
six Roman numerals
you know
the mattress is going to fix bail on all
days of the week at all times that's
what a bail commissioner does
you're going to conduct bail hearings on
issues on bail and decisions regarding
release that's what bail Commissioners
do
issue a risk arrest warrants or other
processes of arrest while we don't do
that regularly justices of the peace can
sign arrest warrants and search warrants
and administer Oaths and affirmations
so everything that's listed in this bill
to empower magistrates is what bail
Commissioners do already
so
I you know I don't see where it's it
changes anything
I'm not sure if that answers the
um
I think that I'm training
um follow-up
um
do you think training would how do do
the commissioners
would they want more training a more
standard training program would that be
helpful
thank you well training is always good
but remember the bail Commissioners are
Guided by the bail commissioner handbook
which is available online
it's issued by the administrative office
of the courts and it's specifically
outlines what bail Commissioners can do
and what they can't do
and so just by looking at the bail
commissioner handbook you pretty much
get an idea of how the whole system
works
the courts meet with us once a year
they explain to us any changes that we
need to to understand or what changes
have been made
what we need to do what we need to know
to do the job
um beyond that I'm not sure how a
training program would be designed
to do more than that I mean I really
don't
um
this is this is a bail commissioner's
work
on experience
and I think the majority of bail
Commissioners that you see in the state
have been doing it for a long time
they have
a fairly good knowledge of what they're
doing
uh I will concede that there are
probably bail Commissioners that don't
do
a good job
but again the police departments know
what bail Commissioners are available
and as I've explained on numerous times
especially in Goffstown
I live in France's town I'm not in
Goffstown I'm 45 minutes away for at
least at least 40 minutes away from
Goffstown
but I have told the Goffstown police if
you call me at three o'clock in the
morning
I know that you have probably called all
the other bail Commissioners that are
available in Goffstown and been
unsuccessful if you call me then I know
that that's what you've done if I answer
the phone and I'm available I'll respond
simple as that and they know that
the other police departments the same
thing
if they call me and I answer the phone
and I'm I'm available if I'm there if
I'm home they know that I will respond
now I can't speak to the reliability of
other bail commissioners because they're
not me I can only tell you what I do
and I do this you know why do I do this
it's a I don't want to say it's a hoot
you meet interesting people
and I like that I like to talk to people
like the face-to-face
and I realize that this is important to
the defendant they you know
it's a moment in time that they want to
forget
I try to make it as pleasant as I can
for him but again I got to decide what
to do with them
and for the most part
they're going to be released on PR
because for the most part it's going to
be traffic violations
minor warrants Petty crimes situations
except for DDS
and I carve out DVS as an exception I
treat DVS completely differently and I
explain to you why I do that
um
my concern with the Magistrate
position is
you know Bill commissioner has been
around for a long time
you know if you look at the statute
turn of the before the turn of the 20th
century they were appointed by Superior
Court and you know in the mid 60s there
was a district court
and I think primarily because no judge
wants to be awakened at three in the
morning
to set bail on somebody that's charged
with a petty offense they just don't
want to do that
and I don't blame them
so let's designate somebody else to do
it an intermediary to do it which is why
we are here that's why we were created
to make it a magistrate and pay you know
the the the rate that you intend to pay
the magistrates
I don't think really
improves the system at all I think it's
it exorbitant cost for a function that
already exists and in my mind works well
foreign thank you
um
I have a question if you can answer it
when you
go to bail someone
are you aware of whether or not they're
already bailed from somewhere else in
the state
uh not necessarily
how would you find that out uh I have to
rely on the police to tell me that now
I can look at the criminal record which
is what I do routinely
the police will provide me with a
criminal record
if based on the record I can deduce that
there is an outstanding
matter pending in some Court
I can try and re and research that but
remember at three o'clock in the morning
nobody's answering the phone on the
district courts
so I have to take a guess
depending on what the violation listed
on the record is
that's going to influence how I think
But to answer your question I don't know
you know I don't necessarily know if
somebody's out on bail thank you
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question we've heard a lot today
about bail Commissioners not being able
to receive the fee
um from an offender when they're
conducting a hearing and I was just
wondering if you could explain to us
your experiences and you know trying to
collect the fee like what happens if
you're trying to collect the fee the
person says no what do you do from there
like
foreign
shooting myself in the head for getting
up at three in the morning to hear that
uh
the the default rate for bail
Commissioners varies by District
now my default rate over five years and
my default rate I Define as somebody
that doesn't pay me up front or doesn't
pay the court on the back end
is about twenty percent two out of ten
I look at that as you know that's part
of the job
I signed up for this if I don't get paid
that's the risk I take do I like it no
do I deal with it yes and you know as I
explained several years ago to
another legislator
you know I think I live in a in an area
where the
the quality of the criminal is a lot
higher than it is normally in in
Manchester
you know in Manchester
they know the drill that the defendants
know the drill they know that they're
going to be released whether they pay
the fee or not
I like to think the people I deal with
they're a little bit more responsible
and that they will essentially pay the
fee at some point
to answer your question
you know I'm going to show out no matter
what
and if they pay me that's great I feel
I go home
thank you for your testimony this
morning
um as you said earlier you and I are
both volunteers
you're probably a much better volunteer
than I am not only for the what you do
about getting up in the middle of the
night and your dedication to providing
your service
but we get uh you know we get mileage
and we get a transponder so there are
some of that so I'm just trying to make
the case between the difference between
the two of us would it would it help for
um
for the bail Commissioners if if perhaps
they were even paid mileage by the by
this system more a small stipend or
anything is that does that have any
bearing on your
and I'm thinking about trying to get new
bail Commissioners to replace all the
people that are doing all that
what are you doing now
well
to answer the first part of your
question
any money would be great
but the second part is while mileage
a mileage reimbursement would be nice
uh from an operational standpoint it's
I guess if you say you know it takes
it's 17 miles from my house to the
Goffstown and back okay
but then how do you build that how do
you how do you recover that from the
court uh yeah it becomes a sort of a
paperwork nightmare
the fee the 40 fee if if that were
increased to cover the cost
it all sort of works out in the end I
think that okay
gosh down 17 miles away Hillsborough is
10 miles away you know it all works out
in the end
but trying to build for mileage I think
would be you know
a bureaucratic nightmare in terms of
trying to get it through the courts and
figure that all out so
I guess to answer your question would it
work
probably not is it a good idea oh of
course I love it
Mr chair membership committee thank you
for the opportunity my name is Frank
policy director with the ACLU New
Hampshire
um again uh much of what I was going to
say Professor sure already touched on so
I'll just uh note one aspect of of why
we support this legislation and that's
so the the debate we've heard around
Bell reform over the last couple of
years including
um this session
is that we have people who are not
trained judges making important
decisions about whether or not someone
should be released and that we need to
ensure that its judges making those
decisions who are trained who are
accountable to the Judiciary and so this
is an opportunity for us to address that
concern that's been raised without
undermining people's Liberty which all
the other legislation before this body
would do and I just really want to point
out the fact that if you look at um HB
38 which which you heard earlier today
or HB 318 which you all heard last week
um in this bill they all have the same
core issue that they're trying to
address and that is they're trying to
make sure that people get before a judge
um uh to determine so that it's a judge
making that decision the difference
between this bill and those other bills
is those other bills require you to be
pre-trial detained for up to seven to
eight or six days this bill ensures that
you're getting before a judge
immediately and we think that's
important particularly as we heard you
know a large proportion of these
occasions up I think it was around a
third that charges will be dismissed and
so ensuring that folks if we really care
about getting people before a judge and
that's what's important here this is our
opportunity to do that in a way that
does not undermine Liberty I also
understand that because particularly
because of felonies first the courts are
overwhelmed right now and so ensuring
that we have a process that is without
hiccups particularly around an issue
like bail it may be better to have this
as a study and my understanding is that
the court would support that and so if
that would be the will that's something
we would also support and we'd be happy
to help in any way but again this is
about ensuring that people are not
deprived of the liberty and that's what
we all care about
unnecessarily then this is the solution
that addresses that core problem thank
you
thank you for your testimony thank you
error calls checksi Trixie lafarb the
firm
foreign
good morning my name is Trixie Lafave
thank you very much for allowing me to
attend this morning I'm a resident of
Londonderry I'm a bail commissioner my
first nine years as a bail commissioner
served for the dairy Circuit Court which
would have been Dairy Londonderry
Sandown Chester I have now moved my way
up to the Manchester police department
and work for them exclusively although
if my local police departments are in
need and they have not been able to find
a bail commissioner I do respond to them
when they call me
um there was a suggestion that our
courts are highly stressed at this time
because of a lack of Staffing
so if you reduce the workforce by 85
percent by letting go all of the bail
Commissioners and bring on 15
magistrates
that is not going to alleviate any of
the stress with the courts
um
the magistrates are at about a hundred
and five thousand dollars per year it's
zero dollars to the taxpayer for a bail
commissioner and that's a significant
tax impact to our taxpayers
there was a question about mileage and
last year men some of you were members
of this committee last year when a
mileage bill was presented and there was
a contingency of bail Commissioners that
came before the committee and asked not
to support that mileage because it would
drive up a fiscal note for us as we have
been trying us meaning the community
four years we've been trying to get the
legislation the legislatures to help us
with enforcement of our forty dollar fee
that was
in 2021 there was a house bill that was
defeated because it had a six hundred
thousand dollar tax impact or fiscal
note attached to it so we didn't want
mileage attached because it drives up a
fiscal note so we're trying to fix the
problem but we don't want to raise the
cost until we can actually fix the
problem at the present fiscal rate so
that's why we have not asked for mileage
again
but the question came up about
supervision
that the magistrates would be directly
supervised by a position within the
courts
bail Commissioners are directly
supervised by their circuit court judge
in their Superior Court judge so we have
two direct supervisors there is an
average of anywhere from one bail
commissioner per Court to five or six
Manchester has six or so bail
Commissioners that is far better odds of
direct supervision than one
magistrate supervising 15 magistrates
we work 24 7. the suggestion is the
magistrates would work 24 7. I was at
the Manchester Police Department six
o'clock Sunday evening and I was there
until 11 30. that's one bail
commissioner out of the 100 that we have
in the state
what are you going to do if you have to
take one magistrate that's working for
the weekend how many you have for the
weekend I don't know responding to Just
One Police Department
it just isn't going to work we do
we really do appreciate the fact that
the there's a
conversation in here about additional
education we welcome it more than one
hour per year in September October would
be welcomed to the bail commissioner
Community having something other than
our handbook would be appreciated but we
also do have direct contact if I have a
question or a concern I can reach out to
my clerk who then reaches out to my
judge and we have a one-on-one via email
usually
so if this bill were to pass by just
removing the word magistrate and
continuing and put the word bail
commissioner back in there there would
be no fiscal impact to the state and we
would still be continuing to do the job
that we have been doing since the 60s
so that is my commentary for today and I
just um I oppose this villain I would
like the committee to give it more
serious thought before they make their
judgment
thank you for your testimony thank you
and the chair calls uh turning head from
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
um
this bill sort of originated last
session I think in
uh in our 10 in my testimony relative to
bail reform bills that were being
proposed last session
um as a way of offsetting some of the
burden that Eve those bills were to have
passed would have been put on to the
circuit court judge system and I already
described that I won't repeat it again
for this bill
one of the other aspects of this and I
did briefly mention it is is in last
session there was the repeal of felonies
first which is moving all the felonies
into Circuit Court the administrative
burden that that that has created has
been significant I can't overemphasize
just how significant this effort is to
just set up and and put this system back
into place
um and and
while we think this bill is a good is a
good idea it does
warrant further study and further
evaluation
um and and as I mentioned last week with
regard to representative Lynn's Bill we
think
this bill
um is deserving of study is deserving of
either being retained or or put into a
study committee either in talking with
Frank Knack one of us will provide you
with language that would substitute this
into a study committee if that's the
committee's desirable get that language
to you or in the alternative we would
ask that it that would be retained in
the committee so it can be heard by the
committee over the summer with a little
more depth than than you can do uh in
the rush of getting all your bills
through we we think this is the right
approach eventually but we we do agree
that it deserves further evaluation and
time to make sure it gets done right and
we also based upon the the stress that's
currently in the system to take on a
whole new system of magistrates that
that currently doesn't exist
um uh the the staff the administrative
staff have simply said they can't do it
it's just not feasible in terms of the
burden that they're currently
undertaking so we do we do ask that it
stay alive but that either be retained
or put into a study so we can evaluate
all the issues whether there is a a
benefit to having a joint system bail
Commissioners and magistrates
what are the advantages remote we would
contemplate that that this would be a
remote process not an in-person process
we think these can be done remotely
judges are doing them remotely and we
think this process can be done more
efficiently and with that that is the
ask will get you language and I'll
conclude my comments be happy to answer
any questions actually one other thing
last week representative Denver had
asked for the for the bail commissioner
handbook to be distributed I truly I
just I forgot to do that I will do that
and I apologize for that delay with that
I will conclude my comments thank you
for remembering that because I did not
um there'd be no questions thank you for
your testimony thank you oh I'm sorry uh
representative side okay
question
the chair recognizes representative
scitec I assume speaking in his capacity
as a bail commissioner yeah I kept my
mouth shut because I wanted to have the
option of being able to speak listen
I've heard some wonderful things but
some not so wonderful things uh one of
the just the SWAT a fly Mr connect back
there uh said that uh he talked about
training I think he is conflating
innocence and guilt with the question
about making a decision with respect to
release
uh the conditions for releases so I I
just I that occurred to me as I heard
him I just heard Clarity you're not
calling Mr kanaka fly you're talking
about this no no not at all but I
it's easy for one for to slosh from one
compartment to another
we're told uh very early on and this is
just a no by the way because I thought
of it it remembered it that the the
magistrates are going to know the
community better they're going to be
able to make a more informed judgment
well it's hard to believe on its face
the bail Commissioners know the police
work all the time
know their Community I we have frequent
let me move to what's productive I have
tried very hard to understand what the
problem is where did what's the
provenance of this but why did and it's
finally occurred to me because I'm
really talking to Professor sharer and
to uh representative Harriet gathright
what's going on here is he identified
and I agree and this is where I think
this should be going is the uneven
training
we what how did they look I trained Veil
I have trained bail Commissioners the
last one who's covering for me today by
the way
he went with me for two months
uh to Pelham wind him in Salem
we it at night he never said no we and
over the years
I learned I made some mistakes but I
think I'm pretty good I don't think
you're going to find a magistrate that's
going to make a this is a bold statement
but I don't think you're going to find a
magistrate making a better release
decision I'm not talking about an
innocence or guilt or going to a trial
but to assess that person look I'll tell
you here's another example of where your
judgment comes in I had two boys two
young men from the Bronx one was from
Queens one was from another Borough they
came up they had they were stealing
shoplifting Adidas sneakers
I'm looking at them different they're
from the
New York are are they flight risks yes
am I going to say you're I'm going to
hold you
because of a relatively minor I mean
it's real but it was relatively matter
that's just not a good exercise of
judgment because what I know what's
going to happen is the judge will
release them the next day out of
Brentwood they're going to be standing
there in Brentwood no Transportation no
nothing is that the right thing to do of
course they were
I think they were probably guilty but I
represent a system and I treat everybody
with respect because I'm tree I
represent the system and that's the
values I tried to inculcate so I am a as
I listen to this I am a thousand percent
uh in favor of this idea of a training a
formal training program look we train
electricians why don't you that don't
have to do with elect uh personal
Liberty Professor Sher talked about
the unevenness of the hiring process and
that's I I think that's where this
really came from and I'd like to ask
talk to him in the hallway because he
likes stories I'll tell them some
stories about unevenness about Judges
it's another day thank you it's all I
wanted to say
thank you for your testimony and with
that I will close the public hearing
on HB 400
no excuse me 46 and I'm going to turn it
over to my vice chair so I can introduce
who
representative Roy
foreign
I will now open the public hearing for
House Bill 400 FN the committee
recognizes chairman Roy
thank you um Madam chairwoman members of
the committee I'm here to introduce
House Bill 400 relative to assault
certain assault offenses and bail
eligibility
this bill is basically creating
the offense of assault and battery on a
police officer
the state of New Hampshire is the only
and I repeat only state in the entire
country that does not have the charge of
assault and battery on a police officer
this bill would introduce the the crime
of assault and battery or police officer
as well as expanding it to any EMS
Personnel firefighters EMTs anyone who's
trying to do their job who's assaulted
by a member of the public while doing so
would be charged with this offense
also part of the bill
it creates
the ability for a police officer to
arrest someone who after being ordered
to stand back from them does not do so
we've all seen cases where police
officers are flooded by people in their
personal space and it never ends well
police officers have many
tools at their disposal and they're on
as far as use of force goes they're
unable to use those when someone is
inside six inches in their personal
space in their face it takes things away
from him it limits their ability to
manage the situation
um years ago there was a study
I believe it was called the 21 foot rule
that
someone running at you with a knife
would be able to stab you before you'd
be able to draw your side arm and stop
him
so anyone inside that zone is a danger
um
so the ability of an officer to say
get back you're within my space and if a
person refuses to do so and they're able
to do so obviously you can't do that if
it's small space and the bill spells out
that
that they would be subject to arrest for
failing to obey that order
right now in this country we are
focusing a very
powerful lens on the police departments
and justifiably so
at the same time we have to be able to
if we expect them to behave in a certain
way and to operate at a certain level of
professionalness we have to do our best
to provide a safe environment for them
to do so
in New Hampshire
right now assaulting a police officers
the same assaulting anyone else if in a
bar no difference at all
assaulting a police officer is not only
assaulting a police officer it's
assaulting the criminal justice system
it's assaulting the rule of law they are
there on the spot representing that
it's not just about the person the man
or woman wearing the badge it's about
what they represent while they're there
and assaulting one of them
in my mind there's no difference in
assaulting a judge or someone else they
all represent parts of the judicial
system and therefore they represent us
would you believe that rule is now 31
feet
I would believe that people are getting
faster
further questions I'm sure we'll have a
vigorous debate during executive
good morning
um
just to get this on the record I'm a
posture I'm a professor at UNH law I'm
also an elected Police Commissioner in
Portsmouth my testimony reflects my
opinion not those of unh UNH law or the
Portsmouth Police Commissioner Police
Department
I'm in support of this bill uh with uh
one change at two locations
um on uh page one
if I can find page one
uh sub paragraph two lines 23 and 25 if
the court finds probable cause to
believe such persons value the
subparagraph shall be considered
dangerous Etc and and be held without
bail I think that needs to uh to Accord
with the Constitution that needs to have
a standard of clear and convincing
evidence rather than probable cause in
terms of the law probable cause is a
lesser standard than clear and
convincing evidence and so I think that
change needs to be made to make it
constitutional and that same issue
exists on page two lines four through
six
um other than that I mean I'm in support
I'm just curious about at least the
three offenses the um but it doesn't
show penalties is that penalty is
somewhere else and yeah that penalty
exists elsewhere in the criminal code so
it's just that these would be new
offenses that would be subject to those
good morning again thank you again David
Rothstein and I'm here on behalf of the
New Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers which uh opposes this uh
bill so a few comments
um obviously we all respect the work
that police officers do and that police
officers and others EMTs and other
related people are in potentially
dangerous situations need protection I
would draw the committee's attention to
RSA 651 colon six one
G RSA 651 colon 6 Roman numeral 1G which
talk about talks about the ability of a
prosecutor to file a notice of extended
term of imprisonment meaning an
enhancement of a penalty if someone has
knowingly committed or attempted to
commit any of the crimes defined in RSA
631 which is the assault statute where
he or she knows the victim at the time
of the commission of a crime was a law
enforcement officer firefighter or
licensed EMT acting in the line of duty
so I would say that there is already in
our law a level of protection that
exists in the rsas that a prosecutor
within a prosecutor's discretion can
file a notice and if a jury finds that
enhancing fact instead of simple assault
the defendant could be convicted well
the defendant would be convicted of
simple assault instead of it being a
plain old misdemeanor there would be a
potential of two to five years in the
state prison so there is already a
provision in our law that I would submit
addresses this this issue which is an
important issue that rsas also address a
situation where someone causes serious
bodily injury or acts with a deadly
weapon and I would certainly say that if
someone causes serious bodily injury or
acts with a deadly weapon against
anybody whether it be a police officer
EMT I would certainly understand at
least in the first instance the ability
to bring a felony and our law is
obviously already provide for that
one of the things that that concerned me
about this bill I guess most and and an
anecdote because I happen to meet with a
client yesterday
was the enhancement of simple assault
the second degree assault when the
simple assault which is unprivileged
physical conduct is knowing or Reckless
and results in bodily injury or
unprivileged physical contact so not
serious bodily injury a client very
recently a man with for all intents and
purposes no criminal record his
significant other brought him into an
emergency room he was suffering from
alcohol withdrawal he was delusional he
did not know where he was he did not
know what he was doing unfortunately he
came into contact with the security
guard and he struck a security guard it
was a simple assault under our laws
under this statute however he would be
charged with second degree assault
because he arguably acted knowingly or
recklessly and also under the bail
provision he would likely be held
without bail and I would suggest that
you know these situations that EMTs and
police officers deal with with people
who are in um the throes of a medical
emergency whether they're suffering from
psychosis substance use disorder
withdrawal they're very difficult
situations for anybody but I I think in
most cases it would be an unfortunate
consequence to say that such a person
should be charged with a felony assault
now if they cause serious bodily injury
if they have a deadly weapon I think I
think that's a whole different story
obviously we would say that someone in
that position
should probably be charged with a felony
assault and we'll sort out later what
their mental state was but I it just
seems to me when I read this bill it
just seemed to me that we're taking a
situation where police officers EMTs
have to have contact with people who are
in significant distress there could be
some flailing around that occurs or some
resistance I remember back when I took
Advanced life saving I was told that if
you're trying to save somebody who's
drowning they often will try to hit you
they'll try they don't realize what
you're what you're doing and they'll
they'll punch you and that's a situation
that unfortunately can arise we don't
like it we don't want it to arise but it
can but the consequence of having
somebody charged with a felony in that
situation seemed to me to be
particularly troubling and particularly
not necessary in terms of my client he's
charged with simple assault and we'll
see if the court system believes he
should be convicted of simple assault if
he should then he should I will um
cease my comments there and I'd be glad
have you ever heard of the CIT training
the acronym can you just uh
so it's called critical incident
training right yeah a lot of the police
officers are taking it to recognize
those people who may have a disability
or whatever and that's why they're
acting out and I know uh from my
experience of
45 years as an EMT and firefighter we
take that into account that if it's a
medical emergency we don't we're not
looking to charge these people with
any crime right right but
the one that just punches me because
they don't like what I'm doing
yeah yeah I think yeah right I think I
just to address the the question
representative I I think
um I I think that if
um
I think obviously there it's the statute
does not recognize that distinction the
statue talks about somebody acting
recklessly
um so the statute does not recognize the
distinction you're talking about in
other incidents I don't know if you've
ever administered Narcan that's another
instance where people coming out of
Narcan they do you know they do flail
around under this statute as it's
written and I understand what you're
saying that person would would be
charged with second degree assault
somebody who sees you coming toward them
and punches you like anybody else
whether it's domestic violence whether
it's anybody else they should
potentially be charged with um they
should potentially be charged with
simple assault
um I don't I don't have your your your
life your life experience and I don't
purport to
um but this statute as it's drafted it
seems to me would draw in some of those
people you're talking about who frankly
should not be charged with a felony
assault
I'm sorry representative Pratt
so I have a question uh for your
testimony you believe that somebody was
drowning with flailing on their arms
around could be charged with a felony
the way this is written yes because they
are recklessly they are recklessly uh
arguably recklessly engaging in
um conduct and inflicting
bodily injury or engaging in
thank you for your answer
representative select
thank you for allowing my question and
thank you for taking my question
um sorry it's taking me a moment to
organize my thought I'm I'm curious
we've had a number of cases nationally
where people have been videotaping the
actions of police
um I'm curious how if they were within
the 21 foot barrier
of this
um how that would relate to this right
that's you know I didn't speak to that
that part of the statute it there are
there is
um a first circuit case that I'm aware
of and I think there's a New Hampshire
case that I'm aware of that does
um
validate or vindicate someone's ability
to be able to
um they have a phone to be able to
record what the police are doing
um it you know it seems to me that that
it's it's possible that this statute
could
um infringe upon that I mean I'm really
I I'm definitely less familiar with the
the this this circumstance and I'm not
familiar with the the necessity for I
mean I can certainly understand that a
police officer needs to be able to do
his job and there are statutes
um you know there's a statue disobeying
a police officer disorderly conduct if
an officer gives you a lawful command
um and you you do not
um adhere to that command you can be
charged with disobeying a police officer
you can be charged with this early
conduct it does seem to me that the
statute in some instances could infringe
on a person's lawful ability to either
observe or to record what the police
representative scitec
um
there's a couple I have two questions if
I make first is with respect to your
client who is delusional
don't you have to have a men's Raya in
order to commit a crime no matter how
devastating it may have been to the
officer to anybody he was not in a he
was not intending to commit a crime so
aren't you mixing a couple Concepts here
I I'm not actually representative I'm
not mixing the concepts my client got
charged
um and and he get charged with simple
assault under this statute he would have
been charged with second degree assault
even though
um the the there were people at the
hospital who said he was talking about
going up to the third floor of the
hospital because he had to save people
who were being I mean just really
nonsense obviously he was not he was not
oriented as to as to time and space
this is where I see the statue
potentially being overbought obviously
it would be great if we could trust
prosecutorial discretion not to charge
those people but the person that I met
the person that I represent has been
drawn into this and yes you're exactly
right if this case goes to trial my
defense will be that he did not have the
men's Rhea or that his act of I think it
was punching the uh the person in the
hospital was not a truly voluntarily
volitional act the bottom line is though
he would have been charged under this
statute with second-degree assault
thank you all right very reasonable but
the other question is
the what I wanted to ask first is you
said that there was enhanced an ability
to uh apply for enhanced penalties
because of the that's great and I I
think you have a point there but doesn't
this
does this bill not remove the discretion
maybe the prosecutor just didn't want to
go after enhanced uh and the enhanced
penalties whereas this bill would
require that because of the nature of
the law enforcement office or whatever I
I I definitely can see I'd have to look
at the specific language of the bill
again but it does seem to me that if you
have
um if you basically it's it's a status
offense so basically if you determine
that the person assaulted had a
particular status then it's a felony
that doesn't I mean to me that doesn't
mean that it can't necessarily be plea
bargained for whatever reason down the
road I don't think
I don't think the bill removes the
prerogative to say that this person
should you know should have a
misdemeanor instead of a felony or
whatever it may be I I do think you're
right I do think that what it does is it
singles out the circumstance it singles
out these particular people because of
their status and it says that a simple
assault should in the first instance be
charged based on that status as a felony
instead of a misdemeanor so I do think
it
does it totally remove discretion is a
tough question I don't know if a
prosecutor would still have discretion
to charge a simple assault but the
message to the prosecutor that the
legislature would be sending is that
it's Our intention that you charge a
I'm not sure if this is Chief refonsky
or
baby
thank you madam chair I often know with
the look when they look at the card that
is usually me
uh
uh members of the committee my name is
John burfonski I'm the chief of police
in Bedford New Hampshire and I'm also
president of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
representing more than 160 Chiefs across
the Great Granite State and we are here
in in support of HB 400 predictably
there are a number of benefits that
arise from this bill but let me speak to
the issues that may have already been
brought up by some of the previous
testimony to Phil fill in the gaps but
first let me say that police officers is
not a week that goes by in the granite
state where one of your police officers
Troopers or deputies isn't engaged in a
struggle or worse in a fight in the
exercise of their lawful duties and
responsibilities and I underscore lawful
duties and responsibilities for example
just this past week one of my female
officers Was Bitten and not by an animal
was bitten by a human who human bite
which we all know is something that
could be very serious
and these sorts of actions go on quite
frequently and more frequently than um
than we would like to see obviously and
more frequently than perhaps you would
like to see in Manchester my colleagues
in Manchester I would believe that they
would tell you that the altercations
that they have in response to resistance
to their lawful commands is is happening
quite frequently I can recall one case
about a year ago when a Manchester
police officer was engaged in a struggle
with an individual who had been arrested
and released on a number of occasions
the officer's leg was broken in
connection with that particular case and
unbelievably the individual who was
charged was released on his own
recognizance and back out on the street
probably while the officer was still in
the hospital
so there's quite a bit of an impact on
the law enforcement Community as we
struggle to recruit individuals who want
to take up the Baton in this profession
and carry on the mission of Public
Safety in your communities
for placing themselves In Harm's Way
each and every day and night here in the
granite state to protect you
and yet there is no statute as was
brought up in previous testimony that
specifically addresses assaults on
police officers the statute with respect
to sentencing enhancement
notwithstanding that isn't after the
fact measure that means that there is
likely no knowledge in the community
that that statute exists there's no
knowledge in the community that
prosecutors are likely to
use that sentencing enhancement when
charging or bringing before judge
someone who assaulted a police officer
so the effect is after the fact meaning
the harm against the first responder
police Fire EMS or police officer
Sheriff Deputy or Trooper has already
occurred so with all due respect a
sentencing enhancement has no
predictable effect on creating a
predisposition not to assault police
officers and we think that and when I
say police officers I would like to
committee to recognize that it also
pertains to all First Responders
we we desperately need to send a message
to the community that on the side of the
road on the street in the middle of a
case is not the time to argue your case
with a trooper Deputy or police officer
that time to do that is before a judge
but not on the street and so this
particular Bill sends a good message and
that is don't assault police officers
there is also opportunities for the good
defense attorneys to argue before the
judge any mitigating circumstances with
respect to the context of how a
particular first responder was assaulted
the County attorneys are under legal
obligation not to bring cases forward
unless they believe that they can gain a
conviction that's part of their ethical
rules of conduct and as one of the
members of the committee rightly
indicated that that requires that a
culpable State of Mind exists to commit
the elements of the charge
so with with that in mind uh and of
course the other provisions of the bill
we we also support but uh I think that
it's incredibly important in today's day
and age to recognize the dangers and the
perils that all First Responders face
this bill goes some good distance and
measure
forward in helping bridge the gap and
thank you members of the committee for
thank you for taking my question
so the last part that you just said that
this this creation of this law would uh
more or less my verbiage send a message
to people people would become become
aware of the fact
that this activity that's defined here
um has penalties and so what
um associated with it in the current law
you can enhance the penalty but nobody
knows that you enhance the penalty so
so what would be the effect of having on
the duties that you perform what would
be the effect on people
um what would it be like when they and
how would that get around and how would
that help could you just expound on that
a little bit sure and and thank you for
the question uh as members of the
legislature every law that you enact uh
sends a message to the community in the
citizens of Granite State and this is no
different I can tell you from my almost
now 45 years of experience having been
on the receiving end and the losing end
of a number of Street battles in my
career that the folks that typically
engage in struggles against police
officers intentionally and wantonly
right are fully aware of what the impact
that may occur if they were to be
convicted of assaulting a police officer
and I know on the federal side where the
penalties are are quite strong that
criminal defendants are
very much aware of what they face if
they engage in that behavior and
activity so uh to answer your question
specifically once if the bill does pass
and is enacted and signed by the
governor there will be some publicity
that will extend from that and the
criminal defense bar will be aware of
that and So eventually folks will be
fully aware of the consequences right
consequences and that's that's something
that is incredibly important to
remembering the context of criminal law
because consequences do dissuade people
from engaging in behavior that you as
members of the legislature
representing all of us don't want them
to engage in
thank you
representative Harry gathright
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question do you keep data on
any of these incidents with the First
Responders
unfortunately in in the state of New
Hampshire we we have no Central database
that would allow us to acquire data with
respect to assaults on police officers
and that extends to all the various
other issues that we face it would be
great if we had one Central Records
management system and database that we
could query every 177 police departments
across the state to determine or a
Judicial database to determine who was
charged who was convicted on certain
crimes including this if it were to pass
so we do not have that data
hello follow-up okay so I guess my other
question would be do you you gave us an
example from a year ago
um in Manchester do you get the same
type of issues across the state
anecdotally as they say right
yes that that is in fact the case do I
have
um cases um that were that I'm
personally aware of and speaking with my
colleagues absolutely uh the media is
replete there was a case recently where
an officer was assaulted in connection
with a particular matter that was
published on wmur's website uh so again
this occurs rather frequently and from
discussion with my colleagues across the
state uh again not a week goes by where
some officer doesn't in get engaged in
some type of physical altercation or
worse
thank you
representative Jennifer
thank you chair and thank you chief for
taking the question
um so I've been sitting here looking
over different things
presently right now under statute
it's it's illegal to commit first degree
assault secondary degree assault simple
assault if it involves a police officer
that can also be charged with resisting
arrest and if there's a serious bodily
injury to that officer it's a class B
felony uh you have an enhanced
criminal penalty during sentencing by a
fighter or EMT so
we've given a lot of tools here for the
prosecution to do their job
and and basically
what you're telling us is that we're
we're going to say stop or I'll say stop
again is that is that you you need one
more one more law to tell them it's not
allowed to do is is that correct that's
precisely correct what we're saying here
is that the measures that are currently
in place do not dissuade people from
engaging in physical conduct that ends
up hurting First Responders and that's
yep
thank you very much
you guys got to get your hands up
do you have do you have a second for one
more question
yes terrific thank you uh Professor Sher
mentioned uh kind of what he felt was a
constitution
I I believe that with respect to
charging uh it's not necessary uh to
present clear and convincing I would
argue that it would certainly be
appropriate for preponderance level of
evidence which is 51 or more as opposed
to clear and convincing clear and
convincing sits somewhere between
preponderant evidence at 51 percent and
proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and so
in a charging situation right it's
appropriate to charge at the
preponderant level and of course it's up
to the courts to decide whether or not
that is sufficient in that case clear
and convincing in my experience
unfortunately the Judiciary blurs that
line in favor of proof Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt between clear and
convincing so I think it presents a
particular higher hurdle for the County
attorneys to be able to overcome when
we're at clear and convincing and again
we're not at the conviction stage we're
good morning members of the committee my
name is Joe Ebert it's ebirt I'm a major
with the state police I oversee the
Investigative Services Bureau which is
your state police detectives uh so I'm
keenly aware of the proximity of my
testimony and your ability to go to
lunch so I will keep this very brief
uh however
um so I did want to start by addressing
something that representative Harry uh
gatwright uh brought up and it uh it
dealt in assaults and whether or not
they're taking a play uh taking place
across the state so I can speak from uh
my own experience having uh been
assigned to troop F which is our
northernmost troop and Troop a which is
one of our southernmost troops uh and
I've certainly seen assaults
unfortunately throughout my career uh
both from uh right from the top of the
uh the state of New Hampshire all the
way down so I do
um I sit before you today in support of
this bill uh on behalf of the State
Police and I say that I think I would be
remiss if I didn't come before you and
offer support of a bill that may deter
a fellow Trooper officer or first
responder for being assaulted so as in
in regard to the uh the first portion of
this bill we are certainly in support of
the enhanced penalty
what I wanted to do though was address
something that I don't think has been
addressed in great detail which is the
last paragraph of the bill and it deals
with knowingly reporting
false allegations false and baseless
allegations about law enforcement
so I wanted to touch on that because
there is as one of the prior speakers
had remarked there is a heightened sense
of judgment and scrutiny on law
enforcement and there should be and we
absolutely should have that and
as an agency we are incredibly
supportive of that notion
however I do I think that we uh with
that
heightened sense of scrutiny we bear
certain uh penalties that are not
they're they're not present in other
professions so for example
if somebody makes an allegation that
you've committed a crime you may be
suspended suspended without pay this may
affect your health insurance this may
affect your uh your pay your ability to
pay your mortgage
and these things are acceptable as long
as the allegation is based in Merit if
it's not based in Merit it was done out
of malice
that's an incredibly difficult situation
for someone to go through
so I wanted to start on just these the
lowest level of allegation where
somebody says on the side of the road uh
you know this individual this Trooper
when they stopped me they yelled at me
uh they yelled at me in front of my
child and they swore at me and it was it
was egregious it was outrageous I
shouldn't be treated like this
so the complaint comes in and the first
thing that we typically do now is we
will watch the the body camera footage
and none of that takes place none of
that it's a relatively cordial uh
interaction their issue to summons and
away they go the outcome of that
complaint is a letter that goes back to
the individual that says your complaint
is unfounded and I will tell you from
sitting on the other side of complaints
like that that's a difficult pill to
swallow if I were to have said the exact
same thing during that stop that this
was said uh that it was done in a way
that was uh unprofessional and
outrageous and it was found that I was
lying uh I think clearly I would be held
responsible at a much greater uh to much
greater detriment so uh what I'm saying
in that uh in a microcosm there is
if there is no
uh personal responsibility for somebody
making an allegation
then there's no prohibition for that
person to do it they don't have that
second thought in their mind that okay I
can make this allegation because what's
the worst that can happen nothing
as it relates to a criminal allegation I
talked to you a little bit about uh what
happens when somebody makes a criminal
allegation against a member of law
enforcement we would never want to chill
the reporting process for that so if
there is misconduct that is taking place
and it is Criminal we absolutely want to
know that
if someone is making a criminal
allegation against a member of law
enforcement for anything other than the
truth what I would suggest to you is
there should be a repercussion for that
if you make an allegation that is found
to be baseless and false that person
should be held responsible for that so
uh with that I thank you very much for
your time today and I'm certainly
available for any questions
representative Newman
thank you for not taking my question I I
just listened to you carefully to your
testimony and there should be a penalty
um do you think um well could you just
explain your reasoning
if you do think this that that it
warrants a felony charge as opposed to
maybe the language that says a
misdemeanor for the first time and then
and then for this goes jumps to a felony
could it be a Class A misdemeanor that
has both fines and jail time potentially
available for it
so thank you very much representative
Newman for the question uh this is
something I considered greatly before I
came in and uh spoke this morning so I'm
I'm happy to opine on that I
I don't think it's the
position of the state to believe uh
State Police to say whether or not this
should be a felony or a misdemeanor I
think that's really something that uh
the legislature should contemplate and
and come to an agreement on if if the
bill moves forward
um what I would tell you is I
I certainly had pause at the notion that
somebody would be convicted of a felony
because it's it comes with such serious
consequences for that individual
um
but I tried to balance that against the
very serious consequences that law
enforcement officer may also undergo for
a baseless claim so I I submit that to
you for further discussion amongst
yourselves at a later date but we are
certainly in favor of people being held
responsible but in terms of the level
which they are held responsible we would
not suggest a a level of crime thank you
nice
does anybody else have their hand
thank you major thank you all so much I
really appreciate the time to address
you this morning thank you is there
anybody else that wishes to testify on
this bill that has not turned in a pink
card
seeing none I will close the public
the committee will be in recess until 12
30.
yeah
good afternoon
at this time open the public hearing on
HB 549 FN
and invite Prime sponsor to introduce
representative testerman are you here or
anyone here on your behalf
second one
huh
foreign good afternoon I am
representative Lauren selig representing
Durham which is Stratford 10. and I am
introducing the bill in the absence of
the person who presented it Bill 549 FN
relative to the definition of domestic
violence
this bill expands the definition of
abuse to include acts of financial abuse
and domestic violence
thank you
how's that
I I'm not going to repeat what I just
said
um and for 20 years I've been on the
domestic violence fatality Review
Committee but most of my work at this
point is as a criminal defense lawyer
I'm a member and past president of the
New Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers but in doing that I
represent both plaintiffs and defendants
in domestic violence and stalking cases
we do not doubt the good intention of
this bill
but it raises a set of concerns
some Provisions unwise some unworkable
and some unnecessary so I'm going to go
through a couple of the provisions
quickly and of course be prepared to
answer any questions
so the first provision letter I which is
talking about financial abuse includes
the provision hiding assets
remember that this statute applies to
both married individuals and unmarried
individuals who are involved in a
relationship but there's a choice to go
to court for a protective order
so in if I was in a two-month
relationship unmarried and my partner
said so tell me about your bank account
or tell me about your 401k and I
declined to do that
arguably that is hiding Assets Now again
the issues that this bill seeks to
address were sympathetic to but the
wording of the bill broadens this in an
extraordinary and I believe unintended
way
if a wife chose to hide assets from a
husband because she wants to leave
part of her exit plan is to create two
months rent and so is not telling her
spouse about that bank account she is
hiding assets and this legislation
defines that she is involved in an act
of abuse
if you go to i-6 that's refusing
reducing or refusing access to funds for
daily living again if you're dealing
with an unmarried couple there's no
legal responsibility of support but
because of the way this bill is written
the statute expands that duty of support
to unmarried individuals and if one
partner is refusing access to funds the
other partner can say under the wording
of the statute that it's abuse to seek a
protective order
paragraph I ate dissipating or hiding
Assets in anticipation of a divorce
first off the easiest thing is to go to
divorce to to file a divorce because
when a divorce petition is filed there's
a specific provision in every case that
bars hypothecating or hiding funds so
this is an anticipatory issue and not
workable because it's not the case that
every spouse knows that the divorce
petition is about to come
so it becomes a proof issue and a little
bit of a nightmare for the court system
to find out when is it that you told
your spouse that you were going to seek
the divorce and it was like well only
after filing so there are real practical
issues in regard to this
additionally these Financial issues are
typically dealt with within the context
of a divorce pretty extensive discovery
which involves both interrogatories and
depositions that's never going to occur
within the 30-weight day window as you
may know in a protective order case
there can be a an ex-party order the
final order is then by Statute within 30
days it is unrealistic for the court
system to manage the issue of
interrogatories and depositions within
that window
um
the I'm gonna go skip to paragraph j4
interference with work such that a job
is lost if somebody loses their job it
then makes it a proof issue for the
court system the family court to listen
to the terms of uh the termination
potentially imposing on the employer the
need to come in and speak of the work
history of the plaintiff which may be
mixed
um paragraph J2 depriving family or
household members of basic necessities
again it broadens the scope of financial
responsibilities to non-mary Partners
and seemingly imposes a duty of support
that does not now exist under New
Hampshire law
in terms of the unnecessary paragraph J5
references cruelty to animals that's
already within the domestic violence
statute itself at 173 B1 Roman numeral
1H also j6 references for sex acts
that's also already covered by 173 B1
that's paragraph one
C so it's a combination as I indicated
to air view things that are unwise
things that are unworkable things that
are unnecessary
to have the family court deal with
financial issues over this shortened
time frame which they do not typically
do will create a morass to our view with
the court system
it creates
enormous burdens for the family court a
court that is as I'm going to guess you
know already overburdened I'm aware of a
case yesterday where a family court
judge said I stay till 8 o'clock every
night
trying to work on my caseload I just
can't do more and for this statute to
add to the burdens of the family court
we think is unnecessary and unwise
I see the chairman nodding so I'm going
to finish and say thank you
if I if I may ask a question or to
myself
um
under the existing statute if you have
representing a defendant and there's a
no contact order
does the current order provide for no
contact through a third party
it could provide for no contact with
children but because third parties a
brother sister not a party to the case
it wouldn't apply to brother sister
parent what I meant was
um in other words I can't pass if if I
have order against me not to contact you
I can't have representative man you pass
it to you without violating the order
correct so that would also apply to work
if I were to go to your employer and and
do something that would cause you to be
in trouble isn't that could that be cons
considered contact to the third party
already it it could and the difficulty
with this also on a practical level is
because it involves Financial issues
it's saying there is no contact but
there'd be this enormous need to discuss
finances correct but it's barred by the
statute and my last question is does the
current order system not already provide
a place for emergency financial support
ordered in the order it can
in in Candor and a majority of the cases
it's not done because these are
expedited hearings focusing on contact
as opposed to full financial planning
the permanent order
permanent order is a one-year order can
be renewed for a five-year window
um in married partner cases it most
typically is a divorce where these
things are settled on a permanent basis
representative Newman
yeah I just have a quick question I I
believe you said that the that the
shortened time frame would have an
um I'm sorry could you just point out
where what language in the bill does
that so the statute provides for final
hearings within 30 days
um so when I'm talking about that short
and time period trying to deal with
financial issues which are ordinarily
the subject of Discovery it would be
very difficult to get all that
accomplished within the 30 days but the
statute itself provides for a 30-day
window from a
for a final hearing the defendant can
ask for an expedited hearing which by
Statute must occur within five days
representative Selleck
thank you and thank you attorney cronon
for taking my question
um so I understand that you're saying
the way this bill is written makes
addressing Financial issues challenging
I'm curious if you can identify if
someone is in fact using finances as
their method of abuse you know say
cutting off credit cards and all other
Financial assets for one party member
how does that get addressed Within
uh within this structure or within the
structure of domestic violence so most
typically those are married couples and
the way to deal with it is by filing a
divorce petition which allows both a
temporary order for support most
typically those temporary orders focus
on child support as well if kids are
involved
it becomes murkier if it's a childless
couple as to what that financial support
looks like the focus most typically is
on housing and a court order as to who
is going to live in the house or
apartment and who pays the expenses for
that
for unmarried people it
there there isn't because there's no
legal connection between unmarried
people in terms of Duties to support
there isn't typically a good way to deal
with it other than ending the
relationship
thank you
um
in some case that I've experienced
the abusive partner who may have been
verbally abusive for an extended period
has withheld has figured out ways of
withholding all finances from the other
partner
so that they then have no ability to get
sustenance or any other provision and so
are you saying that the only way that
they would be able to address that would
be to go through divorce proceedings
that there's no aspect of the abuse laws
that would protect them in those cases
if they're unmarried they they can't use
that would be the typical easiest way to
do it because it creates a separation it
can create protection within the divorce
statute itself there is also an ability
to get a protective order so while you
can choose to get a protective order as
a married couple
now and go do a divorce later it's also
possible to do to just go forward with a
divorce and seek a protective order
good afternoon
it's been a long day uh my name is Joe
Hannon I'm with governors of New
Hampshire and uh I want to keep my
comments it's a very narrow part of what
this would affect it would actually
impact a person's uh Firearms rights and
able to own them uh obviously you're
aware that under 173 B section 4 and
relief for any type of abuse which this
would expand the definition of if they
could lose someone's Firearms rights uh
temporarily or even extended periods of
time if they're if they are convicted of
anything so
um the purpose of that was obviously to
keep uh Firearms other deadly weapons
away from someone who was a immediate
and present danger for abuse to the
petitioner I don't see how many of the
things on this list would be considered
something that would constitute an
immediate and present danger of abuse or
have a potential cause for someone to
fear for their safety and well-being
we're talking about something physical
versus some other things that are
obviously something needs to be
addressed I'm not discussing why you
know what these things need to be how
you can do them that's not my job today
my job is to say that this would give a
huge opening for an area of infringement
on rights that is is not necessary and
um I just ask you to please rethink how
it's going to be done and listing these
under the domestic violence statute as
abuse
if you happen to take any questions
or just go sit down
representative Newman could you just say
again where is the portion of the
there's a portion of a bill that you say
is a threat to uh the whole thing I mean
if it becomes If This falls under uh the
definition of abuse under abuse in a
domestic violence statutes under uh 7 17
173 B4 under temporary relief someone
can lose their firearms uh and not just
after a hearing or a conviction in an ex
parte hearing so this is basically it
would make like an expanded red flag
wall for someone to lose their firearms
when they haven't done anything violent
or to make someone fear for their
physical safety or well-being now I'm
not saying any of these things are good
or shouldn't be addressed in the law but
I think doing it under a specific
definition of domestic abuse is is uh it
will have a lot of unintended
consequences and it would actually
infringe on people's rights and it would
be cons it's a constitutional issue if
you're talking about taking someone's uh
constitutional rights away for a
non-violent crime that they would have
been haven't even been convicted of and
there's no danger to anyone else thank
you
good afternoon I'm Kurt Ehrenberg the
New Hampshire director of the Humane
Society of the United States I'll be
brief I just wanted to commend the
committee
for recognizing and including in the
legislation
uh
animals and abuse of animals as a
precursor
which is a well-known and
studied proven
very telling precursor of domestic
violence so including this in this
legislation
is a terrific situation we were really
happy to see that the more that people
think about
uh the abuse of animals as a precursor
to all kinds of violence in our society
and one thing that we're trying to
Foster in this state is uh better Animal
control officer protocols and things
like that which you may see at some
point in this committee but I appreciate
your time today that's all I wanted to
do was commend you for your work
thank you for your testimony
um we have to give credit where credit
is due the committee did not drop this
this bill was drafted by representative
testerman we're just going to decide on
whether or not it's good
I'll pass on your thanks though and I
see you anywhere whatever thanks thanks
for doing
and we do support the bill as it is
notwithstanding the comments we've heard
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Pamela kylig and I
am the public policy specialist at the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence which I think many
of you know is the umbrella Organization
for our 12 community-based crisis
centers I'm here to speak today on HB
549 as you've heard legislation that
seeks to change our state's definition
of domestic violence we'll try to keep
it brief today
um I think
um we really appreciate the sponsor's
interests in examining ways that we can
ensure that nuanced and complex
experiences of victims are recognized in
domestic violence cases especially when
victims are seeking life-saving services
like protective orders that were
mentioned today there is no question
that Financial abuse and coercive
control are factors and many victims
experiences and can contribute to that
pattern of behavior that can lead to
escalating violence however while the
the Coalition supports the underlying
principle of the bill we are hesitant to
make any changes to the statute at this
time we feel that the current definition
is very comprehensive and we want to be
extremely careful when it comes to
considering any changes to existing law
for some of the factors you've heard
today there's just a lot to consider and
I also just wanted to add that the
governor's commission is also on
domestic violence sexual assault and
stalking is planning to review and
analyze this actual issue this summer as
part of their agenda and we think that
that's a great opportunity for a
multi-disciplinary group of stakeholders
to really look at this thoroughly and
determine what next steps might need to
be taken and we I can also I'd be happy
to share after any research from other
states who have also looked at taking on
this issue there's been varied responses
so again we just ask for more time and
at this I would ask the committee to
either consider retaining or even it
yelling this bill just to give us more
time thank you so much and I'd be happy
to take questions
thank you could you address my earlier
question regarding the finances if if a
person seeks an order against someone
else is it currently within the power of
the court to issue a temporary support
order as part of that restraining or
protective order
um and I might look to my colleague
attorney
okay I was afraid to hold it for him
because yeah so I'm this is I would be
happy to find the exact answer for you I
know I'm not sure if you're referring to
Jade's law which allows a parent to take
a restraining order out for a child or
no I'm referring to whether or not when
there's a hearing for a protective order
if a judge has the ability to say okay
this person is dependent upon you for
their so you need to continue paying x y
and z Oh yes and then that would already
be covered and it would be a violation
if they did not do so yeah that's a
great question and
um I know that um oh it's complex so I
think there's obviously there's divorce
and parenting restraining orders and
then there's protective orders and so in
sort of the when and please someone else
correct me if I'm wrong and I'd be happy
to follow up as well but I think
oftentimes there there's a lot of sort
of checklists that judges go through to
look at the circumstances involved and
what you know if there's a child what
adequate supports would need to be put
in place so like the general question is
I do believe there is something in place
already I think maybe the intention here
is just to recognize that sometimes
there could be maybe by naming it
specifically there could be more weight
on ensuring that that was considered but
there are currently processes in places
that can make that considerate or that
judges have that discretion to consider
that okay but because uh the previous
um the previous person's testimony uh
the attorney regarding the divorce side
of it and the domestic abuse side of it
is well taken so I don't like mixing the
two of those so I'm interested if you
could find out if the domestic abuse
side of it has the um the ability and if
it's used to for them to order support
of any kind yeah I can get a copy of
that protective order I think that would
clarify everything thank you thank you
so much questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
everyone
uh the chair recognizes Sergeant
Catherine
I'll try to write neither next time it
is my name is Catherine shackford I'm a
detective Sergeant with New Hampshire
State Police
um I actually don't have much else to
add to what Pamela said
um the state police is opposed to this
bill as written and I think that she
outlined uh some of the pertinent points
as well that that we would share we look
forward to this issue being examined
with the governor's Commission on
domestic violence this summer in order
to kind of look at these the specific
nuances of of a bill like this thank you
any questions from the detective
no thank you for your testimony thank
you
um the chair recognizes uh Richard head
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch we have
significant concerns about this bill
um as written and Echo the testimony
that the governor's commission is
intending to take up the def the the
definition we do think it is best
managed in a in a sort of extensive
review both of how folks within New
Hampshire would deal with it but also
have these ideas been tested in other
states how has it gone in other states
and ultimately develop a better
understanding of exactly the the
positive and negative implications of
the bill is written
in a highly contested divorce a number
of these items that you see on this list
would become domestic violence petitions
too it becomes a it significantly has a
potential to significantly exacerbate a
highly contested divorce case with
regard to the chairs question
a DV protective order can cover
Financial it is not extensively used but
the statutory reference is in 173 B4
which is temporary relief lists sort of
the items that can be in temporary
relief in and then there's sort of a a
bit of a catch-all other so if there are
specific facts that support it and it's
requested it would be a potential
um uh
add to a domestic violence or a
protective order and with that I would
conclude my comments but would be happy
to answer any questions
thank you um so the the catch-all would
would about today such as
animals
um credit cards that stuff would that be
potentially available for the court to
to make a ruling on
it was the first one animals yeah so
there is a line that says uh granting
the petition or exclusive care custody
or control of any animal owned possessed
release by kept by the petitioner so
that's a specifically addressed item and
then in the other relief it's other
relief including but not limited to and
then has a couple there but in in one of
them relates to business finances but it
would also if there were personal
finances at risk it would
um it could be considered within the
scope of of the protective order thank
you questions
thank you thank you thank you for your
time is there anyone else wishing to
testifying this bill who has not done so
see none I hereby close to public
hearing
and the next one is 15 minutes we'll be
it really is
okay
at this time I'm going to open an
executive session on HB 549 and I record
represent recognize representative
what's the one we just heard
five four nine five four nines executive
session
right
um I move that we itl
um HP 549
and
um we need a second
second
would you like to speak to your motion
representation
um after hearing the testimonies that we
heard today
um I believe that there's a committee in
um the process of looking at all these
issues around domestic violence so
the bill is not necessary at this time
would you like to speak to a second oh
thank you Mr chairman
um basically everything that my
colleague said and I would just add that
it appears that this actually may end up
doing more harm than it would would good
representative Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
representative scitec
oh sorry
yes
representative scitec yes
yes representative Prue
yes representative janvin
yes
representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes
representative tensar representative
Harry gathright
representative Muse
yes
representative Bolton not here
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes gay
and representative wheeler okay all
right and Mr chair
um
all right the total is 16 yay no nay
excuse me yeah and we're opening the
public hearing on HP 315 and the chair
recognizes
foreign
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of this committee my name is
representative Sean filio and I have the
privilege of serving the residents of
Cheshire district 7 which covers Keane's
Ward 2.
I am here today to introduce House Bill
315 which seeks to abolish the gay Panic
defense
as procedural history
this house passed a similar bill in 2022
but it stalled in its high vote in the
other chamber
I now renew the effort to bring equal
dignity to all Granite Staters
the gay Panic defense is a common law
defense which allows a defendant to
argue that experiencing a victim's
alleged same sex flirtation so overcame
the defendant's delicate sensibilities
that the defendant was provoked and
in that agitated State murdered the
victim
this defense allows the murder charge to
be downgraded to manslaughter which
attracts a lesser sentence
put another way
it says if a gay man hits on a straight
man and
the straight man violently responds
resulting in the gay man's death
the straight man has the opportunity to
argue his his murder charge should be
downgraded
to be clear there is no straight Panic
defense
that bears repeating
there is no straight Panic defense
if a man flirts with a woman
and she doesn't like it
she must respond in a rational adult
manner
bite her lip
and walk away
if she loses her temper and kills the
man she must face the full consequences
of the law as we expect of any citizen
there's no blaming the flirtations of
the man for her conduct
yet
New Hampshire law points the finger at a
gay victim for the similar situation and
says you're at fault your life isn't
valuable
the law
ought not engage in this homophobic
hateful victim blaming inherent to the
gay Panic defense
it is a moral Abomination which must now
be left to the Wayside of History
and that's why 16 of our sister States
and the District of Columbia have
already abolished the gay Panic defense
it demeans the basic human dignity of
lesbian gay bisexual transgendered queer
and questioning people and blames
victims for their own demise
further
all of our New England neighbors aside
Massachusetts have abolished the defense
and Massachusetts looks poised to also
abolish it this year
the American Bar Association in
resolution
113A recommends all states abolish the
gay Panic defense
as stated by the American Bar
Association quote the defense is not
really a defense it is a tactic to
strengthen a defense by playing on
Prejudice end quote
it is a obvious miscarriage of Justice
and the continued use of this
anachronistic defense
marks an egregious lapse of our nation's
march to a more just criminal justice
system
I'll close with this chilling reminder
in 1998
in a bar similar to any bar you'd find
in Durham
or Keen
or Hanover
a young gay college student made a
mistake
he hid on some straight men believing
them to be gay it's an innocent mistake
but these men played a cruel trick on
him
they lured him down the road
making him believe that they were
interested but then once he was down the
road away
they savagely beat him
hanging his beaten body on a fence post
leaving him to die overnight
their murder charge was downgraded to
manslaughter using the gay Panic defense
negating the basic Humanity of this
young gay man
clearly I am talking about Matthew
Shepard
tonight
in Manchester
or Hanover
or Durham or Keen
the next Matthew Shepherd could happen
due to the inaction of this body
New Hampshire is better than that
we are better than that
and that's why we're going to take
action
join me and let's demonstrate to Granite
Staters we value all lives
I look forward to taking your questions
as we protect every life in this state
thank you for that testimony could you
remind us what state was that Matthew
Shepard incident happened that happened
just for the record you you had said at
the outset that New Hampshire law
allows this it um it doesn't explicitly
allow it correctly it just doesn't ban
it uh correct it is common law that
allows for this a common law defense is
a uh defense that exists as a result of
a Judicial precedent however it has not
been affirmatively used in New Hampshire
and we should take action before it is
affirmatively used in New Hampshire a
final question for me as if you're aware
of it is there any Supreme Court rulings
on this type of thing yet that we have
we heard any
thank you for the question there is no
U.S Supreme Court ruling on this and
there is no New Hampshire Supreme Court
ruling however because it has been used
in other states other states have
the case that you cited about the young
man who was beaten to death
were there any other circumstances that
would reduce that I mean can anyone take
gay this gay Panic defense seriously
thank you for the question Andy I would
agree that it's hard to imagine that
this is necessary in 2023 that we are
not placing equal dignity on all lives
but the gay panicked offense was used
that was the partial defense and that
was the reason why it was downgraded
indeed there are dozens of reported
cases across the country and that is why
no lesser a group than the American Bar
Association the leading group of
attorneys the leading group of legal
Minds in our country
recommends every state abolish it and
that is why our sister states are
abolishing it it is used it is an
Abomination and that's why we need to
act and that's why this body voted to
there'd be no further questions thank
what oh please
representative Newell
thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry I was a
little a little late on the reason we
have so just to clarify
um you know putting this into
our legislature into our
law is preempting if anything were to
happen a situation like what happened in
Wyoming
um so rather than unnecessary it's
necessary to protect in advance is that
how you would
Define it I think you're representative
yes this is a preemptive action which
our state does many times that we are
preventing this from happening before it
is used
we don't want a situation like this to
occur we don't want somebody's life to
be lost to a gay Panic defense type of
situation
we would prefer that an individual not
lose their life or to have this defense
be used which is again why other states
have abolished this defense before it is
used there
New Hampshire has been on Leading Edge
of other issues and we should be at the
Leading Edge of this issue
thank you
representative saley thank you and thank
you for taking my question
um
I I am aware that um the trans community
in particular is subject to more
violence than pretty much any other
community are you aware of specific
cases in New Hampshire where people have
been assaulted purely because of their
sexual orientation sexual expression
gender expression or gender identity
I I can't decide a particular case but I
do just out of lack of knowledge of a
particular case representative however
it happens every day uh one in four uh
lgbtq people lesbian gay bisexual people
will be the victim of an assault in
their lifetime
um and the similar statistic exists for
transgender people and this comes from
FBI crime data uh the reality is that
the number of lgbtq people who are the
victim of an assault vastly outstrips
the number of CIS or heterosexual people
who be the victim of an assault in their
lifetime which is why one in two lgbtq
people will suffer major depression
their lifetime not because being gay or
being transgender makes you depressed
but being in a society in which hatred
exists make you depressed we need to act
as a society to begin to address these
hateful actions that occur against lgbtq
people and addressing something like the
existence of the gay Panic defense is
one piece of the puzzle we are better
than this as a society
ask yourself the question
ought sexuality be used at it as a
defense against somebody
and ask yourself this question
ought a woman be able to say that she
murdered a man because the man flirted
with her
and then have her murder charge
downgraded because that is the exact
thank you for your testimony thank you
committee
foreign
representative catab
thank you Mr chairman and to the
committee for having me here today I'm
representative Caitlin kutab I represent
Rocky m17 Windham
I come here today in support of house
bill 315. I did want to make one
correction to something that
representative filio said
it is my belief that in the 1999 brutal
killing of Matthew Shepard that yes
Aaron McKinney's attorney did try and
use this defense but was unable to
because the state of Wyoming does not
allow
an insanity defense and it was
considered to be this the same in an
effect so he was actually charged with
murder because he wasn't allowed to use
that sentence
but
in New Hampshire we do allow the
insanity defense under RSA 628 too
in 2018 this defense was used in Texas
by James Miller for stabbing his
neighbor Daniel Spencer to death
after finding out he was gay
instead of being convicted of murder he
was convicted of manslaughter
and was only sentenced to six months in
jail in 10 years probation
as as
representative fellow testified
there are similar legislation in 16
States as well as the District of
Columbia
and the reason why it's needed is
because in New Hampshire we do allow a
an insanity defense and so
we need to clarify that it's prohibited
that you can't use it in this case so
for states that don't allow an insanity
defense this isn't needed
but in states that do this is something
that needs to be clarified roughly five
percent of our population in New
Hampshire identifies as being part of
the lgbtq community
and today you have the power to protect
them and I ask you
to pass this bill to vote in favor to
stop this unjust defense from ever being
used in our state here in New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair and thank all my
fellow Representatives
my name is Jerry Cannon I represent
Stratford District 12 which is
Somersworth and Rollinsford
I am a transgender woman
in 2017 when I ran for school board when
I first
my first couple of years in Somersworth
I won
a school board position
and the very next day I received an
anonymous death threat
oh
resulting in me buying a handgun
because I had no idea where that came
from
it reminded me of
an event that we go through every year
talking about transgender it's a
transgender day of remembrance
this past year
transgender people were gunned down
because someone didn't care that they
I'll have to admit about 80 percent of
the people were Black Or Hispanic
and mostly in cities however doesn't
mean it doesn't happen in the suburbs as
well
we can't
let people
shoot an LGBT person just because they
don't like them or don't like their
their politics or don't like that
they're
um running for a local office or just
I don't know if I need to say more it it
has me still to this day I still worry
about
what could happen to me
I know at home I have a handgun next to
my bed I hope I never have to use it
but if if I have to I will
thanks for taking my question
I don't know if
um thanks for sharing your story I don't
know if my question is best suited for
you but I know you're really informed
about this topic as far as the function
of making claiming a defense when you're
engaged in the legal system is it
possible assuming that
at this point someone's committed a
crime
theoretically that has earned them a
jury trial is it possible that the
defense might select for jurors who
would be sympathetic to such a defense
it anything's possible so I'm not sure
I'm just curious if that's sort of the
risk that's trying to be addressed I
think that comes down to uh how they
interview jurors that would be questions
see no further questions thank you for
good afternoon everyone my name is Bill
Blum and I'm here to speak in support of
HB 350. today I am here to not only talk
about this Bill I'm here to talk about
basic human rights
I believe in the worth and dignity of
all people regardless of gender identity
or financial position
let me say this in a slightly different
way right now this very second we are
all breathing the same air
and we all hopefully at some point today
have had some food
which in turn gives our bodies the
energy to continue to be able to exist
some of us identify as
carnivores
vegetarians
and vegans
choosing to eat meat or not is our own
choice to make this Choice has no impact
on the larger community of eating to
survive
where am I going with us
hopefully it's no secret to anyone here
that I am part of the lgbtq
community living as a non-binary
individual
I unfortunately have lived experience
with discrimination and bias
I lost my job without cause in September
of last year
and I also am having a difficult time
finding new employment
this could be for a number of reasons
some of which might not be obvious as of
yet
living my authentic life has cost me
so far a ton and I wouldn't change it
for anything
as a fellow human being my ass to you is
to not expose me to discrimination
in the potential Final Moments Of My
Life
as the knife enters my body and turns
into my heart
I wish to ask myself did I live a
complete and good life
and not did this blank hole know that I
was transgendered
thank you so much I'm so lucky that um
what a great body this is that so many
people are offing to help with my
newborn I'm very grateful so
um thank you everyone
um honorable members of the criminal
justice committee my name is Amanda
Elizabeth Hull and I represent Cheshire
15 which includes constituents in Keene
Walpole Westmoreland Hinsdale
Chesterfield and Surrey New Hampshire
and I'm here today in support of HB 315
I think the vast majority of New
Hampshire constituents regardless of
political party support codifying lgbtq
plus rights into law and making New
Hampshire a welcoming state
every New Hampshire constituent knows
and loves someone who is a member of the
lgbtq plus community
in my city of Keene the school board
unanimously passed an affirming
transgender policy and Keene State has a
flourishing Pride Alliance by and large
my constituents reject bigotry and
support inclusiveness
I cannot think of another instance in
which a victim's identity can be used as
a defense in a crime and so this is a
long time coming our neighbors in
Connecticut Rhode Island Maine and
Vermont have passed similar legislation
and we want people in our state to feel
safe and we take pride in being a state
that really values diversity
this bill would be a crucial step
forward in establishing legal safety for
the lgbtq plus Community I've had many
members of that Community reach out to
me in support of this bill and I urge
you to support it as well thank you so
hello members of the committee my name
is Linds Jake house and I live in Dover
I am the founder of 603 equality which
is pursuing non-profit status as a
Statewide lgbtq organization I am
non-binary and you see them pronouns and
I strongly support HB
3 15.
as was mentioned before
um Concord High School just put on a
powerful showing of The Laramie Project
a play that shows as the murder of
Matthew Shepard in 1998 Laramie Wyoming
some may think of violent killings like
that as having happened long enough ago
that we're not still feeling the effects
of them today but just this past year at
least 32 people were murdered for being
transgender and lgbtq plus people in our
state have seen increased violent
threats in November a small number of
white nationalists including the proud
boys and their sympathizers showed up
outside the t total or on Main Street in
Concord to protest a drag queen Story
Hour and over 100 people showed up to
show support for the lgbtq community
just after that 603 equality held a
vigil for the lives lost to the Colorado
Club Q shooting attended by 125 people
who shared their deep sadness and fear
and mostly just wanted to feel safe
although the lgbtq Panic defense is used
in the specific instance of manslaughter
a large part of the lgbtq community has
felt the fear of violent death
I felt it when I read about the Orlando
pulse shooting having just coming come
back from a pride Night Out in Boston
that fear is Multiplied for lgbtq people
who have disabilities and who are black
indigenous or people of color
the lgbtq Panic defense blames people
for their own death which is
dehumanizing so we must act to
delegitimize this anti-lgbtq defense and
send a message that lgbtq wives are
valuable I'll email a copy of my
please accept my apology for the
watching of your last name thank you no
thank you and good afternoon members of
the committee my name is Hayden Smith
and I'm from Hanover New Hampshire and
I'm here representing the New Hampshire
youth movement to testify in support of
HB 315
our organization's membership includes
many lgbtq plus young people from across
the state and it is critical that we
pass this bill to ensure that they are
afforded Equal justice under state law
our laws are supposed to protect the
ability of all Granite Staters to live
and express themselves freely yet state
law does not guarantee equal legal
protections for lgbtq plus people thanks
in part to the continued allowance under
common law of a legal strategy known as
the gay Panic defense or the lgbtq plus
Panic defense in New Hampshire
the gay Panic defense is built on the
notion that lgbtq plus people are
inherently dangerous and the fact that
this strategy is still permitted sends
the message that the state believes is
it is acceptable to harm or kill someone
solely for being perceived as lgbtq Plus
in effect this strategy demonizes lgbtq
plus individuals who Express themselves
openly and exposes them to Mortal Danger
suffer with my dear friends and
colleagues belong to our state's lgbtq
plus community
and it is unconscionable to me that the
state treats them as if their lives are
of a lesser value than others
our state owes lgbtq plus people equal
protection under the law but we still do
not have that as long as the gay
panicked offense in similar practices
are permitted
hb315 would Rectify this issue by
Banning the defense through its
prohibition on provocations based on an
individual's gender identity gender
expression or sexual orientation
for the sake of defending the lives of
lgbtq plus people in our state and
upholding Justice For Those harmed or
killed I urge the committee to vote
ought to pass on HP 315 thank you for
your consideration and I'm happy to take
any questions
representative selik
thank you thank you and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm curious how many times you've had
drills at school to protect yourself
um I'm no longer in school I'm 22. um so
I've been out of New Hampshire public
schools for a bit
um we did not have
um
drills pertaining to what you're
mentioning to protect yourself from
lgbtqia people uh you know we do not
have such drills when I was when I was
personally in school thank you may I ask
a follow-up and what did you need to
have drills for uh primarily for um
school shooting lockdowns as well as for
fire drills there was one threat of a
shooting when I was in high school that
representative Noel
seeing as you haven't thank you madam
chairman chairwoman and thank you for
taking my question
um you know I have a son who's in high
school now and kind of seeing what's
what's happening there it's very
concerning a lot of
homophobic and things like that I'm
wondering since you have been out of
high school for a little while would you
see that as a change or an increase or
would you was that your experience when
you were in New Hampshire schools
um when I was in uh school at least the
uh
could I ask you to clarify the question
I guess it would seem to me that there's
been an uptick and an increase in those
type of
um uh and and seeing seeing that
manifested in the high school and I'm
not sure because my son this is his
first year in high school I'm wondering
if this is a change if it's actually an
increase or if it's been steady
does that make sense I'm sorry I'm not
um could I ask an increase in what in uh
homophobic attacks uh okay thank you for
answering thank you for clarifying oh
that makes sense um
um well I will say I do
um I think it is I have seen more
reports at least
um I do keep up with some news in my
school district after I graduated of
um homophobic incidents
um I think some of it may be attributed
to the fact that we are it is finally
becoming we're finally becoming more
aware that such things are homophobic
and people are more
um able to report them without facing uh
as much attribution as they used to uh
but yes I do I have noticed an uptick in
reports of behavior and I'm in the Upper
Valley School Districts at least thank
you
is there somebody named James here
[Laughter]
hello and thank you
my name is James baumersbach I am the
legislative chair for New Hampshire's
Psychological Association I'm also a
practicing forensic psychologist here in
New Hampshire
I'm here today to testify in support of
Bill 315 I thank the committee for their
time I'll be happy to answer any
questions uh to my best of my ability at
the end of my testimony
I would simply like to point out a
couple of points to the committee at
this time
first of all as a practicing forensic
psychologist the question before uh or
relevant in this case is whether or not
first of all that this defense is
used and the answer is yes
um I believe uh information I've read is
that there's been about 200 to 250 cases
uh that have proceeded nationally using
this as a legal defense so obviously
this is a rare but it is used second of
all in about 13 of those cases the
efforts were successful to get this
defense through to a jury so while again
not the majority of cases we do see that
this is a defense that is used and is
successful at times
I always tell you as a psychologist that
I am not aware of any research that
identifies gay Panic or lgbtq Panic as a
legitimate psychological phenomenon this
is purely a legal phenomenon a legal
work of art
um by defense attorneys in order to
establish that there is some sort of
diminished capacity or some sort of uh
uh
mental crisis which causes a person to
lose control of their actions at the
moment that they commit this crime in
short there's no evidence for that as a
reality
so what we have here is a defense that
is sometimes effective and that does
sometimes get used that is based on
illegal fiction
and so in that regard I am in support of
banning this as a legal defense here in
New Hampshire I will note with
an agreement with what else was said
that this is to my knowledge this has
not been used in New Hampshire but it
does not mean that it will not
potentially be used in the future
I would also like to point out that the
American Psychological Association as
recently as 2021 has noted that use of
gay panic and also just the allowance of
gay Panic as a legal defense
um is considered to be a form of
bias against the LGBT community on an
Institutional basis in other words what
we're looking at here is an attempt to
um
recognize the rights of these people to
exist uh and to have score that they
will receive Justice in the same way
that anyone else would expect to have
so I will happy to answer any questions
see no questions thank you for your
testimony
hi um oh I'm sorry
um good afternoon members of the
committee
um my name is Erica Perez I represent
New Hampshire youth movement
um today I won't be reading my own
testimony but one of our members Jordan
King
um who's 19 years old
um so my name is Jordan King I'm a
resident of Milford New Hampshire I'm
urging this committee to pass HB 315
which would ban the gay Panic defense
from further justifying the murder of
lgbtq plus people
as a bisexual woman and part of the
lgbtq plus Community this bill would
protect me and people like me from the
fear that someone could get away with
the unthinkable because I am queer
to illustrate why I think this bill is
important I want to share a brief story
a few months ago I went on a first date
with a guy I only had met briefly and
continued talking to online he was very
nice online but I didn't know much about
him our plan was to go on a little day
trip and I was excited our plan seemed
fun and first dates are exciting before
going I was talking to friends about
going and promised to keep my location
shared with them for safety thinking
about how to stay safe and meeting up
with someone I had largely only
interacted with online I had a lot of
concern
I had a concern a lot of young people in
this era of social media and dating apps
I brought another concern up to them
maybe I should tell him I'm queer before
going in case something comes up so I
don't get I pause for a second and tried
to
keep the conversation lighthearted with
the invention of a new verb gay panic
defensed
of course rationally I did not expect my
date to kill me if my being bisexual
came up at some point during the day
however the fact that I thought of that
and did end up telling him beforehand
just to be safe shows the harm of
allowing someone's sexuality to justify
hateful murder
growing up knowing the gay Panic defense
existed and was the law in New Hampshire
while I was discovering my sexuality and
coming out meant that since my early
teenage years I lived at the
understanding that the law and the
government would look the other way if
one day I joined the list of people
whose lives had been cut short by hatred
that apathy on the part of the state was
an additional weight to the realization
that people out there would hate me for
who I was so much they would want to
kill me
growing up as an lgbtq plus person meant
hearing about hate crimes and thinking
that could never happen to me before
realizing in the back of your mind you
knew it could
people like me
in states with the gay Panic defense
have an additional fear when coming out
because the battle response could
be more than someone not accepting you
but could mean someone killing you
without Consequence the existence of the
gay Panic defense tells lgbtq plus
people that not only do our lives not
matter but the hatred we face is
justifiable and our fault lgbtq plus
people in New Hampshire have lived with
this weight and apathy of the government
for long enough it's past
it's past time in this committee and the
general court recognize lgbtq plus labs
in New Hampshire matter and protect them
from bypassing HB 315 and banning the
um no questions thank you very much for
is there any more wishing to testify in
this bill who has not submitted a card
and testified already
there being none I think all the
witnesses for their testimony hereby
closed public hearing
and the next one is two o'clock ten
minutes uh the community recess until
2PM
thank you
foreign
I will now open the public hearing for
House Bill 590 representative Newman
I will now open up the public hearing
for House Bill 596fn prohibiting the use
of racial profiling and law enforcement
activities and in sentencing
thank you members of the committee
um
HP 596 is a bill that attempts to draw a
couple of very specific lines in the
sand first of all it would prohibit the
use of racial profiling by law
enforcement Personnel in New Hampshire
and it would also prohibit race or
ethnicity from being a factor considered
in determining a defendant's sentence in
a criminal case
um
in 2021 as you know the legislature
passed a series of of comprehensive
police reforms after uh the death of
George Floyd
um those reforms were passed in a bill
uh SB 96 and much of the content of H of
SB 96 was a result of the work of the
liac commission
um
unfortunately there were things that
were that the there were recommendations
that the liac commission made that did
not make it into the final version of SB
including
a provision that would have required the
state to collect uh data on uh on stops
uh made
made in the state and collect racial and
ethnic data on that and the purpose of
that was really to uh to to try to
either either to to basically gather
data to try to determine whether New
Hampshire had a racial profiling problem
um since uh that part of the build uh
didn't make it through uh in 2021
um one of the things that we have
learned is that racial profiling does
exist in New Hampshire it continues to
exist the granite state news
collaborative did a very comprehensive
two-part series uh uh two years after
the liac commission disbanded on racial
profiling in New Hampshire
um so the the issue isn't uh so much
whether or not we're collecting enough
data to prove it the issue is that we we
do have a problem and and as a country
we have a problem with racial profiling
uh the incident with Tyree Nichols
that's been in the news lately was the
result of a uh that of us of a stop that
initially started uh for reckless
driving
um and one of the things uh as I read
the news reports has been disproven
um was the fact was that he actually
wasn't driving recklessly when he was
stopped
um and unfortunately what what has what
happened to Tyree Nichols is not an
uncommon occurrence in this country in
2021 the New York Times did an
investigation
and basically one of the things that uh
that they discovered was that over a
five-year period uh 600 people
were killed in the United States after
traffic stops uh not we're not talking
about arrests here for Commission of
crimes we're talking about people who
were killed after uh being stopped by a
law enforcement officer during a traffic
stop
uh and 400 of the passengers who were
killed had no weapon uh and were not
being pursued by a violent uh for a
violent crime
there are there are over 30 States
currently uh that prohibit uh racial
profiling in one form or another by
Statute and unfortunately New Hampshire
isn't one of them
and one of the reasons why I wanted to
submit this bill in the first place is
is I do think it's important for us to
make a statement of policy that under no
circumstances is it acceptable for a law
enforcement officer in the state of New
Hampshire
to racially profile another person
uh this is aberrant Behavior the the uh
the Bush Administration essentially uh
prohibited it from being done at the
federal level uh back in 2003
and I think sometimes it just takes a
while for us to catch up and one of the
things that I I also wanted to
to leave you with uh is that Governor
sununu when he actually signed SB 96
into law in 2021 so the liac commission
isn't a one and done the most important
part of what this group has done is
creating something which is living and
breathing and will forever live within
the state to keep ourself ahead of the
game
so one of the things that the governor
alluded to was that Delia commission
really was the starting point for
addressing issues when it comes to
police misconduct when it comes to
things like racial profiling it wasn't
the finish line and I I don't I wouldn't
I wouldn't uh propose that that this
bill represents the Finish Line either I
think that there's a lot of work in
addition to this bill
that will will help heal some of the
wounds and and and perhaps help people
in our minority communities in New
Hampshire feel feel safer in their
interactions with police but
unfortunately too many people at this
point uh turn on the news and they don't
feel safe
they feel that there is one standard
that is applied when police officers are
stopping people who look like me
and another standard that's applied when
it comes to people who look like them
and frankly that's not the way our
justice system uh should should work and
I recognize that police officers have a
very difficult job you don't sit on this
committee for over four years without
recognizing how difficult that job can
be how often they're called on to to
rely on their judgment
and sometimes the policies we make don't
necessarily make it easier for them to
do to do the things they want to do
but I think one of the things that we
have to realize is that you know in this
country
um
just Justice needs to be something
that's provided uh to everyone uh at an
equal level on a Level Playing Field and
and when you actually start on the
playing field 10 yards behind everybody
else
when it comes to things like suspicion
of crimes uh that that's a real that's a
real issue
now the what the bill doesn't do the
bill doesn't uh prescribe uh any type of
penalty we're not out to uh to penalize
officers what we are trying to do though
is we are trying to make a policy
statement that will go into our statute
that will Define profiling and what
profiling is
um so that uh so that hopefully uh
training can be crafted around that and
the police standards and training folks
can can basically point to the fact now
that there that this is part of our
statute and that racial profiling is
prohibited in New Hampshire
I also think that just given the events
in in the news
um this is a a very strong statement
this bill would be a very strong
statement uh to send to the rest of the
country uh at a time when our
presidential primaries in jeopardy
um and I think it would be also a very
strong statement to send in light of the
of the events of of that have happened
with
with Tyree Nichols
and if you haven't watched that tape I I
have two thoughts on that there one is
don't watch it unless you're prepared to
see something terrible
the other is if you're a member of this
committee
you almost have to watch it because you
really don't understand
the depth of the consequences you know
when when when when this goes wrong when
when profiling other people goes wrong
it just it it doesn't result in just
minor violations and inconveniences
people can literally lose their lives
because they they may not know how to
handle that type of a stop properly
they may not handle it the way you and I
would handle it and one of the reasons
would handle it is they have an entirely
set of thing different things that they
need to be
afraid of in those interactions that the
long experience has taught them that
they need to be extremely concerned
about
so that that is part of the bill the the
second part of the bill uh would also
would also address uh data collection
around
um
uh racial
essentially around race and ethnicity is
used being potentially used as factors
in sentencing one of the things that we
found uh in our analysis of
Department of Corrections data over the
years as there are some crimes where
there are where people have been
disproportionately uh seemingly
disproportionately sentenced based on
racial factors again the the purpose of
that part of the bill uh really is data
collection to verify the extent of the
problem and given uh the level of
cooperation that we've received from the
Department of Corrections when it comes
to providing data for us on things like
sentencing bills
um I'm uh cautiously optimistic that uh
that the Department of Corrections can
provide the information that were being
asked now that they're being asked to
provide in the bill
and that that information can be used to
uh to either correct uh a situation then
that may need to be corrected or to show
that no and new in New Hampshire
um we don't have that problem or we
don't have that issue but but again
there are so many things in this
committee that come down to having the
right data and so often we don't have
the data to prove it
and just circling back to where we
started
um
with racial profiling uh we tried to
come at it come at this from trying to
get the data first and I think one of
the things that we found is that between
getting driver's license changed and
between uh having Provisions taken out
of laws to create study committees that
then recommend the creation of other
study committees that never get made you
know it's very easy to sort of lose
track of where we are
um and when it comes to racial profiling
I believe the time is right for a policy
statement from US
outlawing this practice in our state
and uh with that I'll stop and take any
questions that folks have
I'm just curious I know you come from
the Seacoast I'm curious if you've ever
had the experience of either being
stopped for driving while away or
stopped for shopping in a high-end store
for being a white man going through the
store
I I have not
um but I will relate an experience I had
to you just last night I'm not quite
sure I should be relating this to you
but when I came through uh TSA I was uh
I spent the last week traveling out of
the country and when I came back in
through customs
the gentleman took my passport and asked
me what's what's the password and then
going password
and uh and he he said yeah you had your
I have a notation here that you had your
identity stolen a few years ago and uh
you were asked to create a password
which I see you did
um
what he did was very nice of him was he
gave me hints
and what that did was it saved me from
actually having to stand by a wall and
wait for another officer to take me
downstairs and interrogate me for an
hour
unfortunately the gentleman who was in
front of me uh was black and one of the
things and essentially we we couldn't
hear the conversation but the part of it
that we could hear was that he evidently
was carrying uh some vegetables or
fruits in from an from another country
uh and uh he was basically told the
stand by the wall and uh he was there
when we left
and
you know his the treatment of the
officer towards that gentleman may have
been perfectly appropriate given the
fact that he uh that he uh
uh that he evidently was carrying some
things that he wasn't supposed to carry
but what was probably inappropriate
was the fact that he kind of gave me a
pass
um that I'm not sure that other people
would have gotten
um and on the one hand when you're the
recipient of that you're you're grateful
for it you know it was nice not to have
to wait around the airport for another
hour at 11 30 at night
um on the other hand
um you know you just wonder
um that not everybody gets that kind of
treatment and I think that's one of the
things we we have to
kind of ask ourselves you know you know
when it comes to to this sort of sort of
question I mean
this is something that's so outside of
our experiences and and the way we were
treated by law enforcement the way I'm
treated as a as a 66 year old white man
um is very very different
um and but but I think the fact that
that we are treated well and differently
doesn't mean that we shouldn't
be thinking of people
who are not white who who may be treated
differently
and to take the provisions uh in the law
to ensure that everybody's treated uh
treated equally
um
so the answer was no
sorry
are there any further questions
no representative Manion
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
my questions about the first part of
this who would make that determination
that racial profiling was used I'm sorry
make the determining who what who would
make that determination that racial
profiling was in fact used uh when
determining whether it was summons or an
arrest and if that is made can that
affect the outcome of the case
what the spill effectively does is
um I think what we try to try to do was
avoid some of the minutia of of
quantifying it and and getting into
those issues what we're essentially
doing is making a policy statement that
says this practice is unacceptable in
New Hampshire or is no longer acceptable
on New Hampshire in the same way it's no
longer acceptable and that over 30 other
states so what I would say unlike a lot
of the the you know the the bills that
we that we do uh this one is more of a
policy statement and once we have this
policy statement and statute you know
and we've we've defined racial you know
what this bill does is it does Define
profiling and it does specifically
identify uh prohibitions you know things
you know things that are things that are
prohibited
um I I think once that we once we have
that uh it will be a little bit easier
for us to figure eight figure out things
like what is the best way to identify uh
the data
um you know that could uh support
um you know the presence of racial
profiling and a stop
um uh and I I also feel
confident in given how widespread this
legislation has been around the the
country and also given the the training
skills that are police standards and
training group has uh has shown I think
you know not only since the passage of
Leah or the recommendations of Leah
committee but but also you know prior to
that
um uh I I feel I feel confident that
once we have the policy statement down
um the training that's provided will
essentially help Law Enforcement
Officers figure out how to carry out
that policy
so long answer but
um I I feel confident in the ability of
our of the of the folks that we have
doing that job uh to help officers make
that determination and if there are
clarifications uh that they that they
need I would hope that they would come
to us if they if they need
clarifications and statute if they think
that would be helpful I would hope that
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee my name is Jane Graham
I'm the Strategic Communications
administrator for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections thank you for
allowing me to speak today regarding HB
596. the Department of Corrections is
opposed to HB 596fn as it's currently
written the department does not have
objections to the intent of this bill
however the reporting requirements are
problematic for our department it would
require us to create an additional
position in order to comply with the law
the Department of Corrections currently
collects and reports out certain data on
its resident population in fact the
department is one of the few state
agencies required by law
to complete an annual report rather than
a semi-annual one
much of the data requested in HB 596fn
is included in our annual report however
this data does not currently conform to
all of the reporting requirements that
are outlined in this bill
while the department is currently able
to report information on a resident's
minimum and maximum sentences our
software offender management system is
unable to separate consecutive sentences
the department would need to add this
option and potentially other features to
our current program to to comply with
this bill which would result in
increased cost to the Department
an exact amount for this is
indeterminable at this point we would
have to work on that with our vendor the
department is concerned with the
language included on page two lines 16
through 20 of the bill
which states the report shall include
research and gather relative relevant
statistical data and other information
concerning the existence and impact of
disparate treatment of non-white persons
in the facilities under the control of
the commissioner of the Department of
Corrections the language in this portion
of the legislation is vague and it is
unclear what other information is
required that would indicate the
existence and impact of disparate
treatment of non-white persons in the
facilities the department is unable to
speculate on what information may be
necessary to comply with the section of
the bill and whether that information
would be available to us
while the department of corrections may
be able to obtain data on race this data
will not allow for a comparative
analysis on sentencing the details and
fact pattern presented for each case
that was used in the determination of a
sentence will not be available or
accessible for the Department making a
complete analysis of racial disparity in
sentencing impossible for our agency to
determine
the department is also unable to account
for an individual who's a repeat
offender and whose previous offense
history may have impacted their current
sentence length
the Department of Corrections expertise
is that the audits division of the
office of the legislative budget
assistant may be more appropriately
staffed and trained to be able to
collect and analyze the information
necessary to complete what is
accomplished in this bill
the Department of Corrections recognizes
and appreciates the intent of this bill
to combat racial profiling and law
enforcement activities and sentencing
however we feel there are logistical
issues that need to be addressed I would
like to thank the committee for this
opportunity today and I'm happy to
is this
uh is thank you and thank you for taking
my question
um is there a possibility of an
amendment that might be uh
I yes absolutely I I think we could work
on an amendment that would address some
of these concerns and make us able to to
do this because we we are able to
provide a lot of this information it's
just that it's raw data information
um and we would probably need to tweak
our system a little bit for some of it
thank you thanks
representative Murray
okay
representative Newman thank you
um
so I I understand your testimony to be
that that your the Department of
Correction is opposed to the bill
but I just want to clarify that a little
bit is it true that you are opposed to
the bill but it has to do with the
collection you don't you may not be
opposed to the collection of the data
there may be some other place where the
data could be processed and become
available absolutely and we collect a
lot of the data that's in this bill and
we actually provided it to the committee
um in our introductory meeting we also
provide it in our annual report for the
most part there are some some pieces of
information that we would
um need to work on our system our
offender management system to be able to
get and I'm not I'm not sure like how
much money that would take or what
changes would need to be made because
I'm not the technical person
um but we we can provide a lot of it
follow up
so is it correct to understand that if
someone else collected it processed it
and it was then available you could then
include it in your report is that it
might but I I think the bigger problem
for us is not the data collection itself
but it's the analysis of the data for
so you know further questions thank you
thank you
foreign
members of the committee my name is
Joseph laskaz I will be representing the
American civil liberties Union in
support of this bill
I will also be uh representing the liac
commission as a commission member uh
where the Genesis of this uh concept
came from in support of this
um you've heard a lot of testimony today
as uh from representative Muse as to uh
the history and concerns of where this
bill is originating from so I don't I
don't want to um rehash that out what I
instead wanted to do was just talk about
three things specifically regarding the
need for for this
um
it took up to last year 2022 for racist
comments and racist speech to officially
be added to the definition of misconduct
for law enforcement in New Hampshire and
um I and I'll let that one sink in it
took up to 2022 for that to officially
be recognized as misconduct and that's
stemming from situations that have
occurred in New Hampshire
um you know I will stick to New
Hampshire specific cases including uh
Aaron Brown horn
um as well as a situation out of
Portsmouth who a personal friend of mine
was called the n-word by a police
officer ended up reporting that to the
Portsmouth PD I didn't end up going
anywhere he ended up committing suicide
months later
there is another situation that was
personally brought up to us
um by an individual in the community who
went through uh filing that went through
the entire process and having it sworn
under oath of a situation that he went
through with a police department where
during the course of his stop he was
called the n-word swore under oath
filled it out paid for an attorney had
this sent his complaint sent to the
Department of Justice who their response
um to it was uh they have reviewed the
complaint filed on behalf of the client
and although the complaint alleges that
the conduct of the police department was
motivated by Mr so-and-so's race it does
not allege a violation of the New
Hampshire law against discrimination
which with the exception of public
education institutions does not have a
provision that in this context applies
to government agencies or actors the
complaint also does not appear to allege
an actual or threatened race use of
force against Mr so-and-so designed to
interfere with his lawful actions or his
rights therefore the unit will take no
further action that's from the
Department of Justice that was a
response that was sent back to our
client
there is a need to ban racial profiling
in New Hampshire or to explicitly name
it and I'm just going to just end this
with what um I had posed to the
commission uh on liac
does any do any of the decision makers
at the table believe that racial
profiling should be banned in New
Hampshire
and if so
what's the hold up
that that's that's really what this
boils down to is whether or not we're
going to send the message to the
communities to all the community members
that we have in the state that that
their concerns are heard and that this
is gonna we're gonna have a zero
tolerance policy in this state when it
comes to it
I'm happy to take any questions anyone
thank you representative selik
thank you and um I apologize in advance
if my question is offensive it's the
same question I asked representative
Muse
um have you been stopped for driving
while black or stop or followed well for
um the charge wasn't I I guess the the
officer didn't say I was being pulled
over for driving while black but I did I
did bring up a situation where I was
leaving my Concord office and traveling
to the Manchester one I had recently
purchased a new vehicle it was a
high-end Mercedes-Benz and since I
purchased that vehicle I've been stopped
three separate times
um all four alleged violations that did
not end in tickets or warrants but was
uh they were asking me questions
including what I was doing where I was
going one of the officers asked me if I
had traveled that road the day before to
which I told them no must have been a
different black person in the white bins
and he said yeah it must have been
um and then uh following that situation
which I did feel that I was profiled on
I requested that um
traffic incident from that Police
Department it did not again it didn't
end in a warrant because there was there
was nothing um I didn't end up taking
anything the uh officer put down that I
was a Caucasian male that he had that he
had followed for a mile I I don't know
how that happened
um
follow-up
thank you and thank you I'm sorry again
my questions are intrusive
um
I one of my very dear friends comes to
visit me from Lawrence Massachusetts and
takes local roads because he's afraid to
take state representative sorry please
please do the content that the bill and
ask the question because of the color of
his skin I'm wondering whether you've
had similar experiences
um
I'm from this state originally I'm born
and raised in the states so my
experiences are all from here I will say
this that uh during the liat commission
we did hear testimony from individuals
on that there was
um specifically uh the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
presented some cases involving
um I believe uh the U.S US versus Garcia
U.S verse Perez uh two Perez's as a
matter of fact U.S versus Jones these
were all minorities who were traveling
the highways and the state police used a
unit called The Met to uh use pretextual
stops to pull people over to expand the
scope of the of the stock and these
individuals were all pulled over for you
know driving with their hands at 10 and
2 on the steering wheel in one case the
officer said that he found it suspicious
that they were speaking Spanish during
the the traffic stop I don't know what's
suspicious about that but uh those that
did happen and those were documented
cases in all these cases
um the courts uh ended up suppressing
using the evidence in granting their
relief
good afternoon Madam Vice chair members
of the committee my name is Miles
Madison I'm the chief of the criminal
justice Bureau at the Department of
Justice
um I speak just on the the narrow
section of the bill the five lines today
relating to the attorney general's
reporting requirements under this
legislation so just some some comment on
on those lines at the bottom of uh the
first page top of the of page two
um we would note that the resource
obligations that would be placed on the
Attorney General's office under this
legislation are uncertain and uh
potentially burdensome because of the
scope of the obligation is not is not
particularly defined there are two
categories of information that would be
included in a report mandated by this
legislation and but the sourcing of that
that information or data is is not
particularly clear under the the
language of this text
uh
the bill isn't specific as to how the
Attorney General would attorney general
would execute its obligations relating
to that reporting requirement so it
appears to require steps or collection
of data that is not currently authorized
and where that collection of that type
of data such as race and ethnicity
relating to traffic stops or other
complaints it is the subject of other
discussions but this legislation doesn't
lay out the pathway or the expectations
for the creation and uh and cataloging
of that information
a couple of phrases to bring your
attention to one is within available
resources this legislation wouldn't make
available any additional resources to
the Department of Justice
um it's unclear whether that would
result in a diminished report or no
reports depending on what the obligation
may be in collecting this data
synthesizing it and producing
recommendations
when I'm speaking of the two different
categories of information this
legislation would appear to to be
capturing the total number of traffic
stops as one category and then also
complaints under this legislation or or
section across the entirety of the state
the total number of traffic traffic
stops is a little bit clearer to
determine what that may be there are
there are records of traffic stops they
it's my understanding that they do not
currently capture the data that would be
required under this legislation that is
uh the race and ethnicity of the
individual or individuals who may have
been stopped it's my understanding that
that happens in some circumstances such
as if an individual who stopped has
provided a self-identified provided that
information as part of a driving record
or other record but that a significant
portion of those records do not contain
race or ethnicity data and so therefore
if it is a requirement then law
enforcement officials may be having to
one either identify an individual and
try to define the race and ethnicity of
that individual or as part of a traffic
stop or interaction
ask someone what their race and
ethnicity are and then record that for
subsequent reporting
the second category of complaints is is
unclear what's envisioned to hear
um
it could be any references to any law
enforcement agency across the state uh
it's not clear to the Attorney General's
office now how to compile track or
compel law enforcement agencies to track
and transmit that data to the Attorney
General's office
it just it's not spoken to in the
the
speaking a little bit to the the product
that is required under this legislation
uh it speaks to a report due July 1st of
2024 which would be reporting on the
results of any review of the the
prevalence of traffic stops and
complaints across the state and include
recommendations there aren't any
criteria in this legislation as
currently drafted
um
relating to what sorts of
recommendations or what the objectives
are of that report so would note that
this this language is is rather brief in
terms of defining the role that the
Attorney General would have what sort of
data collection would be compelled under
the obligations here but not spelled out
in the legislation and then what the the
goals of that reporting would be for the
Attorney General to try to achieve so
thank you all right thank you
yeah
good afternoon everyone again my name
for the record is Joseph Ebert it's
e-b-e-r-t I'm a major with the state
police overseeing the Investigative
Services Bureau
so uh I wanted to start by making a
clear declaration that we are clearly in
support of there not being racial
profiling within the state of New
Hampshire I I come to you today to
discuss uh if I can direct your
attention to page two uh line 20 and
this was part of the information brought
forward by my colleague from the
Department of Corrections uh that
statistical data shall include but not
be limited to
our recommendation would be where this
bill to move forward a specific carve
out for a review of criminal history
uh and a review of the facts and
circumstances of the crime so I think
that what the purpose of this uh is
pretty clear in looking for disparity in
sentences uh what I would submit to you
is oftentimes it's been my experience
that a sentence can be impacted by the
person's criminal record so I think
that's really important to look at a
person's criminal history and what their
end sentence was the second thing I
would submit to you is that there are
times when somebody uh
pleads guilty to a given offense takes
responsibility and says I was wrong for
whatever reason I committed this offense
and you know I throw myself at the mercy
of the Court
that person very well may end up being
convicted of the same crime of somebody
who says Nope I I show No Remorse I take
absolutely no responsibility and of
course that's the person's right to do
so but I do think that that could have
an impact on a sentence where you have
somebody who comes forward and says I
take full responsibility for my actions
and
and I apologize for whatever Act was
committed so I think that there is there
is something to be said to look at the
facts and circumstances of the crime
that was committed and also a review of
the individual's criminal history the
second thing that I I would recommend an
addition of is the addition of the zip
code of the offender
so inevitably any information that is
compiled like this any data that is
compiled like this I think will be
um there's a tendency to want to place
that data against the composite of the
State of New Hampshire so what what is
the makeup of the State of New Hampshire
what is the makeup of the prison system
and uh if there is disparity between the
two why is there a disparity between the
two I think uh New Hampshire as I uh
testified in a similar but different
bill is a transitory State it's
transitory because people come here
thankfully to spend their money and be
tourists and enjoy everything that New
Hampshire has it's trans story because
there are people who travel through
headed to uh I'm from the Seacoast so
quite oftentimes that 18 miles of the
State of New Hampshire they're passing
through just to get to Maine uh but uh
there are also people who come to the
state of New Hampshire to commit crime
we see this on I won't say on occasion
but we've certainly seen people who
targeted uh businesses within the state
of New Hampshire or targeted a residents
within the state of New Hampshire they
just don't happen to be from New
Hampshire but I think that's relevant
information to collect if we're going to
be collecting it we're going to be
looking at it I think it's really
important to know where that offender is
from
so that when it is applied to the
statistics of the State of New Hampshire
we can have a really clear picture of
those individuals who are from the state
of New Hampshire what the makeup of the
State of New Hampshire is and where
people who are incarcerated in our
prisons and our jails are from
so with that I am happy to answer any
questions you may have but I did want to
Just One Last Time emphasize the notion
that we are in full support of the
could you just comment or describe on
because this bill talks about gathering
information on non-white people and
people of of color in the definitions
just uh how difficult is it for the
um State Police to collect information
like when they went on the roadside and
they're using a computer device after a
person has been charged and things like
that we went to a just a thing over at
the State Police once where one is kind
of hard and the other one after after a
certain thing happens
people divulge that information to the
state police could you just
sure some flesh on that absolutely I
think I understand the uh the question
uh representative if I go uh far flung
please feel free to bring me back in but
um it is particularly difficult
sometimes uh to determine a person's
race without asking
uh we find this in uh in and again I I'm
here to testify on this bill but I I
have testified before in similar bills
that
there must be a way to credential a
person's race I don't know what that is
I I submit to you that it would make the
life of the uh the officer the trooper
the deputy who's dealing with somebody
on the side of the road particularly
easier
um if if that was predetermined prior to
that roadside interaction and by that I
mean if you're writing a summons you can
uh you can indicate what uh
what race you believe the individual is
or you can leave that field blank or
undetermined
there has been a great deal of
discussion over well is isn't it really
what you want the officer's perception
or the trooper's perception uh as to
what that person uh what their race is
and perhaps that is that I again I
submit to perhaps that is the uh the
best indicator is what that trooper's
perception is
however I'll tell you that um the
difference between somebody who may be
identified as Dominican or somebody who
may identify as African-American to me
may be difficult to tell the difference
between uh but be maybe wildly offensive
to the individual when I hand them a
summons with the wrong either race or
ethnicity on there so I would just
submit to you that it's uh
it's not easy and I don't think that
there is a approve the proven
methodology on how to determine that in
the state of New Hampshire but we are
foreign
I think I think your answer demonstrated
the ability for anyone
to to determine uh accurately just by
Vision to do that
um and and I think in that that display
we had over at the state police state
they were very careful to say we don't
want to be guessing
and and I think my question was more
designed towards on the roadside it
sounded like you had a drop down menu
and it didn't have the right number of
choices or maybe the choices that would
help you do it even if you knew what it
was you couldn't do it on the roadside
but once they got to the station whether
they said told you what their race was
or or whatever you were able to at least
in some circumstances be able to
determine the race of the individual
yeah I I think what you may be talking
about there is uh when you when you take
somebody into custody as opposed to when
you write a summons so when you write a
summons every everything is done right
there at the side of the road and uh
whatever determination you're going to
make in that race category is made uh at
that moment uh when you take somebody
into custody there is absolutely the
opportunity to have a much uh greater
conversation with that individual uh
perhaps they disclosed to you uh what
race or ethnicity they identify as or
perhaps there's some other indicator to
you in the course of your conversation
as to what that is so I think that may
be what you're you're getting at is on
the side of the road when you initially
take somebody into custody do you know
at that moment uh what their race and
ethnicity is you may and you may not is
the answer and you may have more
information about that when you're back
at the police department
Representative no
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I'm thinking about the concerns that
both you and the Department of
Corrections have
um with the uh collection in in writing
a report
as regards what uh representative Newman
was saying when you are collecting that
information
um does it not matter more uh what the
officer's perception is rather than who
you know what their actual ethnicity is
I mean I would think that it would
it would be yeah that would be the point
of collecting it right is what the
officers so uh uh thank you very much
for the question and I think your your
question is the uh is the question that
I don't think that collectively this uh
this legislature has come to a
conclusion on it's it is very difficult
um it seems like uh when I have these
conversations about uh well is the right
way then just when the person hands you
the license there's an indicator on the
license that tells you what their race
is so it's done by the time you get to
it uh but then I I've had similar
conversations where people say but but
that's not really what I want to know
what I want to know is what is your
perception of the individual that you've
stopped uh and in those same
conversations people say but you you
know it's it's going to be wildly
inaccurate so the the officer the
trooper is going to uh he's going to
make an assertion that in his mind he or
her mind they think is correct it's just
not it doesn't happen to be accurate so
uh
I I would love to answer your question I
I think that the rest of the legislature
would enjoy it very much if if we had a
definitive answer but unfortunately I
think that's that's what we're working
toward is like what is the best way to
capture that data because we're
certainly supportive of looking at that
data we want to be able to show that we
have we don't have anything to hide that
if somebody uh there was testimony
earlier or there was a statement that if
somebody is
nervous to drive on the highway of the
State of New Hampshire because of the
color of their skin that's horrible we'd
never want to see that and we want to be
able to show the data that supports that
that fear is irrational that is my my
greatest hope is that we are able to
show this data and say that's an
irrational fear you don't have to have
that fear you can travel in this state
no matter who you are no matter when you
want to travel no matter where you want
to go it's the nuts and bolts of getting
to how are we able to get that accurate
data and I don't know the I I personally
don't know the specific answer to that
can I ask a quick follow-up
um very quickly is it is it possible to
uh have a well I guess in the in the
process does an officer create a report
that is not actually uh something that
is shared with
um the the person who's being charged
you know to be able to collect that
information without uh the what you're
saying is the concern of misdiagnosed
you know uh misascertaining yeah so uh
thank you I I think what you're saying
is uh so how do you make that
determination without uh putting at risk
the the chance that you offend this
person what I would submit to you is if
we were to make a determination on what
the person's race was but we were then
to not turn that over to the individual
who had been arrested I think there
would be some a heavy level of uncomfort
uh on the part of the individual who had
been taken into custody I think they
would they would want to know they were
you know so you will tell me everything
about our stop you just won't tell me
this one thought that you had while we
were uh well you were taking me into
custody so I think
um that's a perfect example of it seems
like okay well you know what you want to
do you want to collect the information
but you don't want to offend somebody
and you want to be able to analyze at a
later date it seems like a simple
concept but I think there are some
complexities within it understood thank
you
thank you thanks for taking my question
um on the topic of complexities and I
don't know if this is going to sound
like I I hope I don't
end up phrasing this in a way that I'm
not supposed to phrase questions because
I don't mean it in that way
um but is it not the case that the
perception of all of the perceptions and
beliefs that an officer has in a
particular situation are relevant to
their actions after the fact
um and leading you know once they've
established those perceptions isn't that
I mean that's kind of the purpose of
body cameras and I don't mean to be I'm
not trying to argue I'm just introducing
to you I guess I'm trying to form it as
a question because I'm not supposed to
argue with you and I'm not trying to but
like that's the point of body cameras is
to see the officer's perspective and so
it seems to me like knowing what they
were thinking is relevant for evaluating
the decisions that they made but I don't
know if you have any feedback on that
so I I'm not sure that I understand it
but I'm going to do my best and I
please correct me if I if I'm not going
where you think I should be
um yes it is important to know what a
trooper or an officer is thinking at the
time at which they took a person into
custody
there are certain things uh that they
not may not be able to accurately Define
so I I and this goes to representative
Newell's question earlier is it then
what what you're asking or what the the
body is at the
legislative body is asking uh is We
Believe As A legislature there should be
a mandate as to what the perception of
the law enforcement officer was at the
time uh that they had this interaction
what the perception was of that person's
race
if that is in fact what the legislature
deems is the correct path forward
I think that's something that law
enforcement would uh box slightly at in
that
there's a high probability that you're
going to get inaccuracies in there but
if you're comfortable with those
inaccuracies and the data when it's
looked at later those the inaccuracy of
the data is is analyzed just as
importantly as the actual numbers of uh
the people and their their races
then I think that that's a path forward
that we would March down we're just
we're waiting for guidance from this
legislative body as to what way we move
are there not inconsistencies in the
ex between inconsistencies between the
experiences that officers believe they
have the things that they believe they
see or hear and what actually happens
regularly in regard to other
things aside from race for example I
thought he had a gun it was a cell phone
and do you still proceed with recording
that information even knowing that there
are histories of inaccuracies
yes absolutely uh and I think that's a
great point to say that's a perfect
example of something where you say I had
a perception at the time I thought it
was X I now know it to be y uh I would
submit to you that if what the
legislative what the legislature is
looking for is a declarative statement
on the part of law enforcement that when
I had interaction with this individual I
thought them to be African-American
uh then that is the guidance that we
would need from the legislature the
difference between the two items that
you're talking about uh and this may not
be like when when Joseph was uh uh
testifying uh there I can't speak to his
uh
his life experiences I can't speak to
that but what I can say is the uh the
difference between saying
I thought it was a a firearm and it
turned out to be a cell phone is
material to the action you took I would
argue
whether I thought you were white or
black or anything in between is not
material to whether or not I write you a
summons or I take you into custody and
that's I think the difference between
the just those two scenarios but again
I'm I'm submitting to you if if what the
legislature is looking for is a
declarative statement from law
enforcement
what was your perception of this
individual's race at the time you came
into contact with with them then I think
that's what needs to be asked for
no no
representative
major I really hope that you feel like
you are not the one on trial here
because I feel like we've kind of
slipped on that slope and representative
we are going to move on representative
selig
thank you thank you major for taking my
question
um
last week we heard some testimony about
someone else's spill about police
education at the Academy I'm curious
whether there's ongoing training
for Troopers in terms of anti-bias or
learning to recognize and own their
their
own bias whether whether they know they
are aware whether they haven't whether
they're aware that they have their bias
or not yeah so thank you for the
question and yes there is ongoing uh
training that takes place on uh bias and
that's what that was part of the Lee act
recommendation and that is part of our
now uh built-in yearly training that we
uh that we take part in as a division of
State Police every every Trooper every
member of the division of State Police
uh goes through that training
I think
are there any further questions
thank you thank you all very much for
the opportunity to speak is there
anybody else wishing to testify on this
bill that has not done so already
it has been the custom in this committee
to ask you to please submit your
testimony or anything that you would
like to rebuttal to an email to the
thank you again um committee for taking
uh my my testimony again my name is
Joseph Wisconsin for the record and just
what I wanted to say was just that uh in
regards to what the Department of
Corrections had stated as the concern
for them and how they would be gathering
the information we do support that
concern and do believe that possibly the
LBA could be the solution by requiring
them annually to to have this report
thank you
is there anybody else that wishes to
testify in this bill that is not
submitted a pink card
seeing none we will close the public
hearing for house bill 596.
and that will be the end of our business